we have another emergency order this
time coming out of Tucson Arizona may
not be as serious as what's happening in
Ohio but people are freaking out about
it nonetheless a hazardous material leak
on I-10 and they've issued a shelter in
place order we're also learning more
about what's going on with the Ohio
toxic chemical spill we got a viral
video of a woman walking into her yard
showing all of her chickens are dead
this is a typical Suburban looking yard
this this is not there's there's no
visible signs of chemical leak or
anything like that there's walking the
yard dead chickens and so we're
wondering about what the government's
telling us that the water and the air is
safe and there are many who think and I
would have to agree probably not the
case we'll talk about that plus Elon
Musk is shutting off starlink he's
saying that Ukraine may start World War
III and some in Europe have uh have come
out already said you know what it looks
like that's that we're already there
this may be the case yeah yeah maybe
it's all hyperbolic still don't know for
sure maybe it will erupt into something
bigger but we got some stuff going on at
home and because uh we here at timcast
are downwind from that toxic chemical
spill you know we're kind of worried
about it as well Plus West Virginia is
going to be heavily impacted by this
potentially the water base could be
seriously affected by it and uh let me
just say we're hearing some crazy things
I can't say too much but I'll leave it
at that and we'll get into it before we
get started head over to timcast.com to
become a member click that join us
button and then sign up and you'll get
access to exclusive members only
segments from this show we'll have a
members only show coming up for you
tonight at 11p games you don't miss it
plus you're supporting our coach our
cultural Endeavors you know we're doing
an event on April 14th in Austin Texas
the event is sold out and it looks like
for this event we're probably going to
break even if Lucky it's because you
guys are members were able to do shows
like this the idea is to bring people
together so they can meet meet each
other share ideas plus we're launching
this this coffee shop and a coffee
company because we want to create
physical spaces where people can hang
out so don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about what's going on
with this uh this chemical leak and more
is West Virginia delegate shirelli
thanks for having me who are you what do
you do well I am my name is Gina
shirelli I am the delegate from West
Virginia's 78th house district which is
southeast portion of mon County right
outside of Morgantown and like you were
saying with the water stuff a lot of
these maps that I'm seeing all these
areas affected uh all of them have my
county in it so naturally I have to be
concerned and I have to be concerned for
about 18 000 people so it's um it's
really not easy to get questions from
people about water water safety when I
don't have very many answers I I spoke
with a couple people from West Virginia
American water today who they said that
you know officially that the the water
is is fine it's being monitored it's
being tested they have a secondary
source of water that's ready to go
should anything happen but that's all
that I have I have no no further details
I'm almost in as much dark as the the
people that live in the district and the
affected areas well we should we'll
definitely talk about that plus I'm
really interested to hear about the
shape of West Virginia obviously we are
setting up shop here we've been setting
up shop here but a lot of people need to
understand what's going on with even a
state like West Virginia which is Maga
country has its elements of wokeness so
thanks for hanging out this should be
fun we also got Phil Labonte hanging out
hello everybody I am uh philabonti uh
lead vocals for All That Remains uh and
I am here to uh get into the
conversation
hi I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com and I keep
knocking over this UFO uh I have to stop
now search
that's what she does oh my gosh I
shocked me
um hey guys I am at surge.com I'm ready
to go if you guys are let's go yeah
let's jump into this first story man
this crazy stuff we got this from
timcast.com breaking shelter in place
issued in Tucson Arizona following
hazardous material leak on I-10
civilians within a one mile radius have
been ordered to evacuate the stretch of
road has reportedly been closed in both
directions at milepost 272. civilians
within a one mile radius in order to
evacuate the Arizona Department of
Transportation has not issued an
estimated time for i-10's reopening as
of this report uh reports publication we
have this video from raw raws Roz alerts
is that he said let's see if we can uh
we can play this take a look at this let
me get the uh audio going for you guys
there we go
oh my God so I don't know what that
yellow stuff spraying out of there is
but I certainly wouldn't want to be
anywhere near it
so there it is I mean simply put they
say Tucson's National Weather Service
cautioned drivers of dense blowing dust
prior to the trucks overturning
motorists traveling along I-10 should be
prepared for rapidly reduced visibility
below a mile to blowing dust images and
video from the incident show what
appears to be yellow and red smoke
emitting from the overturned truck which
is reportedly carrying nitric acid
according to Pima County's office of
emergency management and Tucson fire
this seems like it may just be an
accident and accidents happen so my
question for you guys I'm wondering is
it because of what's happening in Ohio
we are now laser focused on things like
this that we probably shouldn't be that
worried about or I mean or or is there
another reason we typically I'll put it
this way
we usually don't hear big news about if
one mile evacuation orders and shelter
in place orders I mean that I feel like
that'd be big news no matter what
whenever it would happen but maybe we
just don't care so they never it never
makes Twitter it never makes the news I
think that I think you're probably right
that it it's uh people kind of focusing
on this stuff because of the the
situation in Ohio
um I think that Ohio is dramatic uh it's
clearly something that the the the the
EPA and transportation TSA are not the
uh judge
and TSB or whatever like or they should
be paying attention to that I think that
this this situation in in Tucson is
likely just an accident you know
unfortunately but we don't hear stories
like this I mean I kind of feel like if
there was a it's a one mile radius
evacuation I feel like if that were to
happen at any other time we'd be talking
about it I think only I think the only
reason that that really I do that I
think so personally I feel like it's
hard to go down the uh the rabbit hole
not hard to not go down the rabbit hole
it's do we believe in coincidences maybe
things like this happen all the time but
it seems a little suspiciously close to
it I mean you can't help but wonder and
then it also seems concerning because
you know we mentioned mayor Pete who had
that big press conference but failed to
mention what I've seen people talking
about as the worst man-made disaster
that ever happened on American soil is
what's happening now in Ohio in Ohio
yeah and we're like two hours away from
there we are not very far from that at
all that's creepy definitely in that
radius Tucker Carlson suggested we're
under attack
I mean but you look at what's going so
for one thing I I think it's fair to say
it's a fact that the power Grid's being
attacked we've got numerous reports of
extremists I guess whether you believe
it or not but numerous reports of some
kind of extremists shooting at power
substations and knocking electricity out
so like that's happening but then you've
got I mean I don't know how you look
you've got the toxic chemical spill
you've got the balloons in our air the
objects floating in our airspace
interfering with with civilian
commercial airlines
and uh yeah I don't know I can't help
but feel like our infrastructure is
being attacked you've got food shortages
in certain areas eggs specifically but
then you look at the culling of chickens
and and this is what this is the
messaging we got when when we talked
about it people were like you keep
blaming Joe Biden for the cost of eggs
but you're not telling people people
about the avian flu that's sweeping
through the chicken populations and I'm
like oh yeah like in New Zealand and
South Africa where they're calling
chickens too why are they calling
chickens different reasons for some
reason everybody's culling chickens in
different countries maybe just a big
coincidence
or I don't know maybe there's something
else going on Mike dewine the governor
of Ohio did this press conference today
where he said that the train that was
passing through the state authorities
weren't notified of what it was carrying
because it wasn't considered a high
hazardous material train and that means
like that there weren't enough chemicals
on it for it to be considered dangerous
from the explanation the governor gave
and that makes me think that this this
must happen more often than we realize
and this one just kind of blew up on
social media I mean if you saw the
videos of the trains on fire there was
no way you could look away and then on
top of that they followed up with a
controlled burn that looked like
essentially Chernobyl I mean that's what
people are conscious of right have you
guys ever seen Aaron Brockovich yeah I
mean this stuff happens you know what
was it what was that story like they
were polluting the groundwater and then
people were drinking chromium or
something yeah hexavalent chromium or
something like that it was killing them
all yeah so is it that it doesn't is it
that we're noticing that it happened in
Ohio and then it happened in South
Carolina and then it happened in Houston
and now it didn't happen in South
Carolina and I don't believe it happened
in Houston but I don't know you were
reading something earlier so what
happens is you get a train that derails
in Ohio and a mushroom cloud and a
controlled burn animals are dying and
then the next time a train derails
everyone's like it's happening again but
it's like yo trains derail like all the
time yeah like
112 or 150 per month yeah over a
thousand people with the number of that
of trained derailments that apparently
happen all the time this one or least
the one in Ohio seems a little bit
aggressive because again the mushroom
cloud you could see from space so
something there seems a little bit
different plus we were looking at the
reporter that said there may have been
more poisonous chemicals in that than we
originally thought somebody's lying
somebody is lying and I don't know who
it is but somebody is lying and Pete has
today said we've done you know the
majority of testings and I think it's
like 200 and however many of 400 homes
and uh there's been no detection there's
no detection of what chemicals like what
are you telling us he's saying that
everything's okay 10 days after the fact
right shouldn't he have been there by
now shouldn't we have heard more about
this I don't believe a word he says and
I don't think that he has any you know
it doesn't matter what he says because I
don't even if even if I believed what he
says I would be I think that like even
if he's telling the truth or he believes
he's telling the truth I don't think
that they they have accurate information
I don't think that they they have the
that's really I guess what it boils down
to I don't think that they have accurate
information to give to people I think
that they're spitballing and guessing
err on the side of caution yeah I
remember I was in downtown Chicago a
couple decades ago riding my bike and
then I saw smoke coming out of like the
10th floor of a building and I see
people walking up to the building and
they're like going like this and they're
looking at it and you know what I did I
went the other way I'm like yo if
there's some kind of leak or who knows
what's going on why are you walking
towards it well they want to sue you or
something like that what is it what is
it called uh rubbernecking yeah sticking
your neck out and trying to go look at
something and uh man it's kind of crazy
because I've just always known that
lesson I guess my dad taught me that he
was a firefighter it's like you see
smoke you get the away from it yeah yeah
but regular people they go towards it
and you think that like that was like it
was really dramatic the the burn in in
Ohio it's not like you know everyone
here agrees that it looked something
like a mushroom cloud or like an actual
volcano erupting like go the other way
and anyone yeah anyone that can get out
of there it's probably a good idea to
leave I can't imagine that but you know
but what if we can't go well that's a
different story I mean so so here's
here's the question here's the question
I got you know you can't ignore it right
I mean what's going on in Arizona people
are posting videos of it maybe this
stuff happens way more than people
realize it is really really bad but
nobody knows or cares right so it's kind
of like uh that there's that experiment
they did where they took a guy and they
put him in a room and they said you know
we're going to have you do be part of a
study just fill out this paperwork while
he's filling out the paperwork they blow
smoke under the door the dude then gets
up and goes to the door and feels see if
it's hot and then yells hey there's
smoke there's smoke in here and then he
goes and opens and calls some people in
they then do another trial
same thing they tell some people you're
going to be in an experiment come in
this room and felt this paperwork they
put three people in the room have them
all sit down start filling out paperwork
blow smoke under the door and you let
the people do then see the smoke look at
everybody else look at the smoke look at
everybody else go back to filling out
that paperwork the bystander effect is
really yeah hey if nobody's out I'm not
gonna and then there was another really
funny experiment uh I can't remember
what show this was they have people go
into like a doctor's office and then
they're sitting down and then one by one
people come in and sit down and then a
bell rings and every time it does all of
the actors stand up
and then the bell rings and they sit
down and the person who's like not in on
it is confused it's like what's going on
then eventually joins in and starts
doing the same standing up and sitting
down it's like why would you do that
it's the craziest thing people do not
think independently and that's dangerous
so here's what I'm saying with this
Arizona stuff I bet this stuff happens
all the time and they never have to
report on it because nobody cares but
now because of Ohio somebody sees an
orange gas coming out and they post it
on Twitter everybody posts it then
they're forced to say okay evacuate when
you should have evacuated in the first
place but they didn't want to say
anything because it would freak people
out and make them look bad yeah
I mean do we think that there's maybe a
hyper fixation on these events that
happen afterwards because they want to
lessen the attention that's happening on
higher welts well it increases the
attention
like this I mean like like here we are
second night you know starting a show
off talking about toxic chemical spills
because of this and people are scared
now that the derailment in South
Carolina and Houston were toxic chemical
spills but as far as I can tell they
weren't I think there was like something
with Houston where they're like
concerned about a potential leak but
there's no real you know there's no like
smoke going anywhere or anything like
that whereas with Ohio there's a
gigantic black cloud filling the sky and
animals are dying and stuff like that so
I'm just saying the government probably
wouldn't warn you if they don't have to
warn you yup that means for all you know
you could go outside and be walking into
a cloud of radioactive garbage and
they're like just don't say anything
otherwise we'll look bad
you can trust the government to do that
I guess you can absolutely trust the
government to try and hide things
absolutely a number of trained
derailments or trained collisions happen
in extremely rural areas right where
it's easy to say it didn't happen I mean
one of the big things with all of this
is uh social media right people filmed
these things happening they definitely
definitely filmed uh the fire they
definitely film the explosion it makes
people more aware of keeping an eye out
for this but if you're in the middle of
a cornfield and your train topples over
even if it doesn't have chemicals on it
you know really it's up to the companies
involved Amtrak in this case Norfolk
Southern to say something and why would
they if they don't need to we got a
super chat from ca2ca Outdoors that says
Tim per the NFPA they were 433 500
hazardous material incidents last year I
think it's laser focus on an incident uh
it's on a huge scale
um yeah but here's the thing about
hazardous material incidents
that could mean like someone in an
airport spilled a bottle of um of
acetone and then it's like ah we got an
acetone spill like ah all right we gotta
get this cleaned up fill out the
paperwork and there's like a puddle on
the ground but you can't drive through
it you can't put equipment through it so
they got to get it clean somehow things
like that where it's like nobody's gonna
die because someone spilled a gallon of
acetone if someone stuck if someone
vomits on a plane they consider that
that a Hazmat right because it's you
know yeah biohazard yeah I don't know
are all these events going into the same
file folder at the office you know yeah
mushroom cloud from that you can see
from space somebody threw up on an
airplane and somebody mentioned too in
the chat that nitric acid will basically
put you out if you breathe it in so
don't get anywhere near that stuff and
there are people driving through this
Cloud let's jump to this next story from
ABC News because now we're gonna start
getting freaky there were more toxic
chemicals on the train that derailed in
Ohio than originally reported data shows
it's from last night so it may be you
know it may be things that have already
been reported that people finally
figured out uh ethylhexyl acrylate a
carcinogen et cetera I think we know
about this but now we got this from The
Daily Mail don't tell me it's safe res
residents of East Palestine expressed
fears about returning after it's
revealed there were more toxic chemicals
on derailed Ohio train than originally
reported and thousands of livestock left
dead
yo
thousands of livestock let me see if I
have this uh this video here let me see
uh where's that video there we go check
this one out I'm gonna play this play
this clip for you guys and uh
this this is what I found Amanda
Brashears was going to feed her five
hens and rooster this morning when she
discovered them all lifeless practically
in the same position with no signs of a
predator entering their enclosure I'm
beyond upset and quite panicked because
this
they may be just chickens but they're
family that's right it says their family
this one they cross the line they killed
chickens damn well they weren't eating
them I mean that's okay but uh yo here's
what I think I think this whole town is
blanketed in a toxic stew they can't see
and the chickens are literally the
canary in the coal mine and this lady in
the video she goes if it can kill
chickens now imagine what will happen to
us in 20 years and I'm just like 20
years lady they're dead now what's gonna
happen to you in a week here's what I
think they're chickens they're low to
the ground the chemicals are raining
down on everything and everyone the
chickens are outside so the chemicals
blank at everything the chickens like to
Flat their little wings and dust up the
air breathe it in and Peck the ground
eating ingesting it and dying humans
aren't eating things off the ground but
this lady's walking around outside
wafting all that garbage up into the air
probably breathing it in yeah I wouldn't
be surprised if we're looking at a few
months and people are in the hospital
with scarred lungs or whatever kind of
damage chemical burns who knows
that's so the idea of that like if you
if there's a massive amount of of
casualties coming in the next that could
pop up in the next couple months I mean
I mean I'm not even sure how to process
that I mean the chickens are dead yeah
one you just have to wait you just have
to wait to see if it happens that must
be the most terrifying thing about
living in this area right now it could
be fine it could definitely not be fine
yo they said the air was safe
yeah the chickens are dead though
they're saying the air is safe they are
safe and they're not they're not finding
any chemical residue inside people's
houses but where are you finding it are
you testing the outside Bill you're
testing the ground are you testing the
sidewalks like water they're get they're
giving you a statistic that's easy to
write I mean some places are saying
they're seeing some detection I think
it's like Cincinnati's water department
but that it wasn't a big deal and
they're you know I it's hard for me not
to feel like a lot of regional agencies
are being asked to suppress information
or they're not able to test fast enough
to get the accurate information out kind
of through no fault of their own because
they've never had to deal with anything
like this you guys remember the algyl
bloom in uh where was it Superior or
something yeah and then all of a sudden
these cities on the Great Lake had no
water
because the algal bloom toxifies the
water you can't drink it and then within
a 40 mile radius of these cities there
was no water everything was bought up
everybody rushed to the grocery store
and bought whatever bottled water they
could and then it was all gone so people
were forced to evacuate because there's
no water to drink the water was toxic
I mean people go through what four
gallons a day something like that as an
average person the person I think I
think they're saying an emergency
emergency situations they're advising
what is it like a gallon for three days
that's to drink emergency situation yeah
for an emergency yeah yeah if you're
irrational I think it's like a gallon a
day I think people go through a lot more
water yeah like when it comes to like if
you're bathing and stuff like that it's
like oh there's bathing's no question I
mean the average person's probably using
like it's like four gallons a minute in
the shower right yeah it's ridiculous is
it really that much I mean I don't know
for sure but it's it's multiple gallons
per minute bro think about this how many
gallons of water can your bathtub hold
and how long it take to fill up your
bathtub yeah I mean usually usually
they're like I think they're like
15 gallons or something like that no way
too they're way more than 50 to 100
maybe the gallons in a bathtub yeah wow
okay yeah yeah yeah I mean have here
look look up a 50 gallon drum you ever
see a 50 gallon drum yeah yeah I mean
try taking a bath in one of those things
good luck I mean bathtub might even be
more than that it just depends on your
bathtub I suppose but yeah they tell you
like when a storm's coming to fill up
your bathtub with water in the in the
event that something bad like the pipes
get busted up or something happens you
can't get access to water oh yeah
there's 72 gallons of typical bath that
holds all right let's see there you go
look at that right in the middle 5200
the water is definitely the most
dangerous game because this lady's
talking about you know 20 years or
whatever it doesn't matter because like
you said she's coming home to dead
chickens now they're right there
underneath all of it down but if this
stuff makes it into the water I mean
look at West Virginia look at the amount
of area that is affected by this so if
they might be facing some sort of Health
consequences in the next what six to
eight months who knows where places like
Charleston Huntington and Monongalia
County my district who knows what kind
of problems we're going to have two
years from now three years from now it
sooner than that all right take a look
at this image me being generous Stu
Peters tweeted this out he says just put
this in perspective the contaminated
Ohio river is the largest tributary of
the Mississippi River
you can see the Ohio River basin this
whole area man so it's happening just up
right here this explosion
if all this stuff gets in the Gets In
The Water excuse me it's spreading out
over everything look how much of
everything west of the Appalachians just
just yeah man
yeah that's your water
this is a big a big concern for us and
that's why the uh the the chief of staff
came by today and said do you want an
update regularly from the West Virginia
American Water people I said of course
because obviously I want to know as much
information as I can get I don't know
how much they're going to be able to
give me but I talked to them once today
and of course they said that it's fine
it's being tested we have secondary
source of water ready to go but do
believe them
I want to well yeah I also want to
believe that you know they have my best
interests they want to help me stay and
live longer that they want to end Wars
and they believe war is bad and uh
there's a lot of things I want to
believe and it might be fine today but
as we know water moves downwards so what
about three days from now what about
next week right and I think that the
people that I spoke to I don't think
that there's anything malicious about
them they were I think that they are
working doing the best that they can
with the information that they've been
given but do I think that they have the
whole picture I mean I wouldn't if I had
to guess I would say no because I mean
the government doesn't lie right what
would happen if the word got out too I
mean this is two-thirds of West Virginia
and not to mention I mean almost all of
Ohio but like let's speaking from the
perspective of West Virginia like what
do you think people would do if the word
got out that the water actually was
contaminated and they couldn't drink it
oh it's pandemonium pandemonium it would
be it would be uh saying a circus
doesn't even do it justice because it
would be way more aggressively violent
and and it would have just detrimental
to to no end you couldn't even quantify
it it's almost the whole state of Ohio
and like the state of Indiana West
Virginia Tennessee Ohio is the fifth
most populated state in the country
people you know like that there's a lot
of people in Ohio never mind the people
in Tennessee and and I mean this isn't
that one mile radius that we were just
talking about in Arizona this is entire
States effectively yeah so there's
the level the level two people you know
to the degree to which people need to be
prepared is
I I've tweeted this you know I was often
that in the future we're going to look
back and be shocked at the idea that we
we would literally flush fresh water
down the toilet
like literally just waste it there's
going to come a time where it's going to
be hard to Source water there's already
issues with the Great Lakes where we've
been depleting them and then
restrictions had to be put in place so
that they could be replenished naturally
and and maintain then you get other
states like I think it was Arizona that
was suing trying to take Great Lakes
water arguing that it's part of the
United States we have access to all the
water sources but the Great Lakes
Coalition includes I think Ontario
Canada so it's like it's an
international treaty you can't interfere
with it but taking a look now at the
entirety of Ohio I can only say I
absolutely hope it really isn't that bad
but hope and a couple uh you know five
bucks will get you a cup of coffee so if
if it were me and and I was in the
direct impact area of the Ohio River
basin yo I'd be I'd be filling up maybe
I'd maybe go buy like 10 50 gallon drums
and just fill them up seal them up I'm
not sure if my ignorance of how bad it
actually is would it would be like
considered Bliss or is detrimental
because it looks really terrible but for
for as much as I'm actually like
educated about this kind of stuff it
could be actually no big deal I don't
know it doesn't look good though
all the Farmland yeah yeah I mean I hope
it's no big deal I hope everyone is
totally fine I hope those chickens just
got really tired and went to sleep you
know what I mean but I think you should
go get the water because it's worse
comes worse you use it when the power
goes out some other time or you have
that resource on hand my problem is just
there is no way to know and it's hard to
know that the only way we get through it
is just by waiting to see what happens
we are now in a completely defensive
position to this and nobody trust me I
don't even know if defensive is the
right to describe it uh trucker and
tourists in the Super Chat saying what
about the food supply there's thousands
of Acres of Farmland yeah yeah yeah
we're reacting all that Farmland I don't
know man that's my point though we only
we only have the ability to react we
don't have any choice but to deal with
the consequences and that is how do you
even prepare for something that could
potentially be such a big scale like I
said I hope it's totally fine but how
could it be they just burned a ton of
chemicals into the atmosphere isn't this
what environmentalists always say we
should not do isn't isn't like the world
basically blanketed in radioactive
particulates because of all the nuclear
bomb tests we did there was something
about that I was reading like it's hard
for us to date certain things because we
just blanketed the planet and yeah we
messed up nuclear fallout of some sort
well that too we messed up no we messed
it up sorry I haven't spoke no I mean we
did mess up I agree for sure that's why
we have to use like surgical steel
coming from like World War II ships and
everything yeah because it doesn't have
the background radiation inside of it so
like new steel harvested or like refined
today is going to be radioactive is that
what it is uh I think so that's why we
literally go down and find those old
chips because it's been kept underneath
the water and thus isolated from all
that particular that's what I understand
we like d radioactive it or something
somehow like we're humans we're pretty
smart we can figure that out can't we no
idea I have no idea no idea I don't know
anything about it sounds like someone's
ready to make a billion dollars and they
can figure that one out Phil yeah we're
looking at you hey look I got some
studying to do then apparently how to
get the radiation out of metal the
Labonte the face of do you redo
activating that I mean if I could I'd
love to take a look at these pictures
that Stu Peters posted this is crazy
stuff right here we got this tweet Stu
Peter says Ohio this is what's happening
to cars if you're driving through spurts
of rain 70 plus miles Southeast of the
East Palestine incident yeah that's like
relatively close to where we are I think
that's like where you are comfortably
close door uncomfortably take a look at
these pictures
so okay all right maybe this is nothing
I don't want to you know it's a tweet
saying this is it's it's just people
posting on the internet we don't know
that it's true but look at these photos
they're they're covered in I don't know
man it looks like salt almost like look
at this these streaks yeah it does look
like it looks like someone drove their
car through like New England right after
yeah after like the salt but it looks
like it looks like the paint even like
kind of flaked off or something
especially here like what is this that's
a weird residue yeah yeah I mean weird
residue there was no way to avoid that
that cloud was black there was
definitely residue falling back to earth
right it's just the question of is this
residue toxic I guess people doing that
it says no I really don't want to get in
whether or not I want it inside me it's
going to be in like 10 years you're
going to be watching YouTube and you're
gonna be watching you know Tim cast iron
really old people I'm just kidding I'll
be 47 so I won't sound like that but
then all of a sudden ads gonna play and
it's like did you live within 200 miles
of East Palestine Ohio yeah yeah you
made and are you suffering from
breathing problems you may be entitled
to a large cash settlement contact the
law firm of non-logic Hodgkin's lymphoma
or no yeah I said this yes but one of
the Hazmat responders to scene said
everyone should go get their health
evaluated right now so they have a base
point to to track what happens next to
their bodies because you don't know
what's going to happen so having a basic
physical right now will be able to
potentially help you in a class action
lawsuit he didn't say that part I did
but you know if you can't tell what's
wrong with you it'd be easy for a
company to be like oh well how do we
know you didn't already have markers for
leukemia
apparently people were saying like Aaron
Brockovich was was saying something
oh yeah yeah Aaron Aaron Brockovich is
speaking up now asking Biden to step up
as people fall sick at animals drop dead
after Ohio trained derailment could this
be what Knox uh Biden out of of the race
maybe a failure to respond to an obvious
dis like massive potentially the worst
disaster chemical spill in this country
yeah I mean he's already not he's
already extremely unpopular I don't see
why it couldn't be a situation where you
know people are have a significant turn
against the administration he's he's not
the plot of The West Wing they're like
one of the seasons that like Republican
is doing well in the race and then
there's a factory fire or something and
he just can never recover from it I
could be misremembering this I was never
never a West Wing fan you're not a
political nerd well I mean um there's
one I can't do episodic TV it's I just
don't have the patience um but yeah I
mean I don't know but the fact that
Aaron Brock which is is making remarks
you know right yeah they made a movie
about her oh yeah with Julia Roberts
yeah and she I mean that she did uh you
know she you did win the case I don't
remember the details of the case but
yeah it was like chromium in the water
or something it was a big finding so how
would Biden respond to this to handle it
you know we're 10 days I don't feel like
he's given a strong response to it is
there any way for us not to look at him
and be like why did we not have us I
mean I've I've heard maybe you can speak
to this more that uh the Red Cross isn't
doesn't really have a strong presence in
the area that there's not a lot of
information that people are having
problems in the government you know the
government agencies are doing nothing
I've probably heard about the same as
you but it seems like that there is no
response of any kind from any level
literally nothing and I've even seen
unsubstantiated but journalists are
being arrested that are trying to get
one at least and I always I always like
to but that was that was at a press
conference yeah and apparently he was
just being noisy and he was like doing
his live reports they tend to do but I
mean I just I always can't help but
think what would happen if the former
guy this happened underneath him this
would be world ending news if this
happened oh yeah this would be the worst
possible thing it doesn't matter how it
happened it would be his fault so now
that I mean because it's binding I just
you know what I heard I heard Biden did
it
[Laughter]
it does seem like something he'd do yeah
I know a guy and his brother knows one
of the people who lives just outside of
the Town whose friend lived nearby he
said he saw a bud all right right there
good enough for me if it's good enough
of them why isn't it good enough right
exactly absolutely good enough so uh
someone close to the Biden
administration office
says that Joe Biden personally derailed
the Train the person close to the office
was the homeless guy in the alley but he
was physically close to his office so
I'm telling you the truth that's the
narrative that's how they play those
games man yeah yeah but no in all
seriousness I don't think and the Biden
Administration came out and just said
the air was safe
that's about it and now there's dead
fish washing up in streams there's uh
one guy who breeds foxes as they're all
sick and the chickens are dead yeah the
chicken's being dead that crossed the
line green Javier is going to be like no
that's just a coincidence we said the
air was safe everything's okay like
they're just gonna continue to try to
sidestep this which is crazy what would
you do I'd leave and and we've even
talked about leaving here now we're
we're down uh down uh wind from the
incident we're not in the direct water
impacted area because we're in the the
Panhandle but
still people are saying like hey look
man there someone super chatted just now
saying looks like a storm is going to
come through and those storm patterns
they move Eastward which means we could
get rained on with this stuff yeah so
what should we do should we lock up the
chickens keep them safe and protected
and keep them out of the rain that rain
comes through it could kill the chicken
they'll probably keep the chickens out
of the lock and keep the chickens in the
coop this is tough because if that stuff
does come through the rain and it rains
here it's going to go in the ground and
there's nothing we can do it will be in
the ground everywhere and there's no way
to protect the chickens other than
building a sealed
airtight you know hyperbaric chamber
that we Pump Air and food into to keep
them safe and that's just because
they're little chickens you know we'll
still be breathing in all the garbage
and getting sick
yeah I think I think you know the
challenge for you uh
delegate is that what is that is that
what I say is that to say delegate like
yeah that would work okay uh is
um I mean your your county is much
closer you're in the water radius I mean
what do you do how do you what what do
you do I I've had a lot of people ask me
that question and this is my least
favorite answer to give to that question
is I don't know I have to sit here and
wait for the information to be drip fed
to me I'm praying to God that the
information that I'm getting is accurate
or at the very least you know at the
very least accurate best case it's it's
helpful or you know it will provide a
little bit of of comfort but I don't
know what we can do we're just at the
mercy of this this extremely unnatural
event it's possibly what I can't think
of any worse man-made natural man-made
chemical disaster that's happened in on
American soil so we just have to sit
here and effectively take it and all I
have to do is you know I have to trust
the science trust the experts you know
this is this this speaks to how badly
trust has been damaged in the uh in the
in the government generally I mean I'm a
Libertarian leaning kind of dude anyways
so I don't generally trust the
government but when you've got your
average people that have spent two years
dealing with all the pandemic
inconsistencies we'll call it between
you know about the the treatments and
what the best practices are it's been so
back and forth and so erratic and so
um just so so inconsistent you can't
expect people to look at the government
and be like oh yeah I feel good about
the information that I'm getting and I
feel confident that you're telling me
that this isn't going to be a problem
and I believe you I don't think that
there are a lot of people that feel that
way anymore I think it's telling that
Biden has not publicly addressed the
situation Nation obviously Americans are
concerned about it if it really is like
things are okay then have him come out
and make a statement about it have
Kamala come out and say make a statement
about it I mean we got we got a super
chat from Brandon angel said my buddy
lives in Wellsville Ohio he's 20 miles
out from the incident he was told not to
drink the water anymore he's been having
headaches chest pain and feeling sick
sick since it happened I believe an
imageless profile super chatting a live
show on the internet more than the Biden
Administration on this one when a
stranger or someone I've never met
comments and says a guy I know is sick I
believe it because I just I saw a video
of dead chickens and so when the bite
Administration comes out and says
whatever they want to say you know you
know what I would say to people
here's my advice
we're close enough
to the to the the the the wind to the
air that if a storm rolls through this
stuff could hit us as well so the only
thing I'd say is you can see the black
smoke
do you trust the media don't know
do you trust the government probably not
so then make the decision for yourself
and that might mean you may decide to
evacuate that may mean you make less
money that may mean you struggle to find
somewhere to go and wait it out safely
for what how long a month
or
you decide to stay
and you may make the wrong decision me
personally we're actually looking at
maybe you know just doing rescheduling
the show and maybe going down somewhere
for a few weeks because we don't want to
get caught up in a storm that might roll
through but then what we got the
chickens here anyway not every person
can leave so what just the IRL crew
leaves that's tough man that's a tough
decision so my advice to people who live
in the area is if you can get out get
out
and figure it out if you can that's my
advice I'm not saying you should take it
I'm just saying if I were you and I
lived directly in the water basin of
impacted area yeah I'd probably buy a
bunch of water right now fill up as much
water as I can and even now it may be
too late because this has been going on
for what to a week and a half now yeah
and maybe too late it's been a week and
a half of this yeah
that's kind of worried and this is what
really causes my heart to hurt so much
as I think about the places that I've
been in West Virginia through work or
anything political or otherwise and I've
seen the hills I've seen the haulers I
know the people that are there they've
been there for Generations they're not
going anywhere anytime soon it doesn't
matter if nuclear bombs are going off
but they just have to sit there and have
this happen to them and there they'll be
lucky if they even get information
that's semi-accurate from any agency any
level of any government it does not
matter that it's just going to sit there
and happen to them if it's going to rain
on them and it's going to ruin their
life and they can't do a thing about it
we normally save super chats at the end
but we've got a bunch of them that are
coming that I think are good and
definitely fact check but Tyler B says
the rain is hydrochloric acid I don't
know if that's true but he says Vinyl
chloride Burns releasing hydrogen
chloride which bonds the water vapor in
the clouds stay out of the rain at all
costs now I don't know if that's true
you want to look that up I do know that
they said the vital chloride will burn
creating hydrogen chloride and go up in
the air that's something they reported
in the press and that makes sense the
hydrogen would bond with water vapor the
uh well I have this from something about
earlier today the EPA says that because
they burn the vinyl chloride there is no
threat of the hydrochloride like
hydrochloric acid yeah they said there's
not there's not an issue but somehow I
just don't believe these people say you
know yeah actually a tip that
something's uh something is a mess
I'm looking it up
because I think this is really important
right now man I mean especially for me
because you know we're here acid rain
hey take a look at this from uh USGS the
U.S Geological Survey
acid rain uh and then one of the things
that was in the let's let's uh what are
we looking for uh here we go
hydrogen chloride which converts to
hydrochloric acid well that's strange
this says uh
acid deposition commonly called acid
rain is a term applied to all forms of
atmospheric atmospheric deposition of
acidic substances rain snow fog acidic
dry particulates aerosols and acid
forming gases water in the atmosphere
reacts with certain atmospheric gases to
become acidic for example water reacts
with carbon dioxide in the atmosphere to
produce a solution with a pH of about
5.6 gases that produce acids in the
presence of water in the atmosphere
include carbon dioxide oxides of sulfur
and nitrogen and hydrogen chloride which
converts to hydrochloric acid and
they're saying there's no risk we burned
it all off and you're good to go don't
even worry about it
they're burning the vinyl chloride
creating hydrogen chloride going into
the atmosphere which the
usgs.gov literally says can convert into
hydrochloric acid and produce acid rain
so was this was this like a local police
decision to burn this like no maybe it's
Norfolk Southern they worked with the
Ohio EPA or uh they're the train
operator and they're like the best way
or best bet to prevent this thing
exploding and sending shrapnels was to
have a controlled burn there's there's a
couple people in the chat in the chat
that are saying that they've got family
that are sick or that they're feeling
sick that are in the area and this is so
the other part of this EPA update that I
used in uh and updated on the story
today is that uh again I'm just gonna
read directly on the evening of February
13th the US EPA discontinued air
monitoring for phosphagine and
hydrochloride Community air monitoring
wait wait wait wait read that one more
time on the evening of February 13th the
U.S EPA discontinued air monitoring for
phosphagine and hydrogen chloride
Community air monitoring
so they're saying you're good you can
see here we stopped tracking it they're
saying after the fire was extinguished
on February 8th the threat of vinyl
chloride fire producing phosphagine or
hydrogen chloride no longer exists
maybe they say you're good Tim don't
leave DJ says stay every time we talk
about this I can hear Luke gradkowski
screaming all the way from Florida about
the air on 9 11. yeah the EPA said it
was safe but it's a huge Scandal yeah
Jon Stewart goes on TV and before
Congress all the time they came out and
said the air was safe to breathe get to
work and now all of these First
Responders their lungs are Scar Tissue
cancers they're dying that's some of the
most that's some of the darkest stuff
ever man I mean if you can like it's not
a bad idea to the I know everyone's
gonna have a feeling about masking but
now is the time to pull out that 3M mask
that you know the big ones right there
right but how interesting is it that now
you have a bunch of people who seem
asking as you know a form of Oppression
by the government which I totally think
is fair but this is actually the time
when we needed it yeah this is the time
where you need like but that you know
yeah this isn't like where a t-shirt's
gonna work you need like serious I
already said people should get their
significant others uh gas masks for
Valentine's Day all right that is true
so I just want to wrap this this this
part of it by saying
if if I was in anywhere near this I'd be
calling a relative and being like can we
come stay with you for a little bit yeah
maybe maybe just let the rains come in
give it a couple weeks I don't know
maybe it's too difficult I get it but
for every for everybody else get water
like even if you're not in the area you
should have some storage water in your
house and food yeah but think about this
it could be two weeks or three weeks or
four where you decide to go on a
vacation go visit relatives a couple
States over
but maybe if you stay and these
chemicals are killing chickens it could
be a lifetime of cancer or disease I'm
not saying I know for sure I'm not a
doctor you know it so it's hard I'm just
distrusting of the official government
statement but maybe they're not wrong I
just would personally not believe they
were right so that's just me but we got
some other uh some other shocking news
too because as I mentioned uh we have
this tweet from the recount a moment ago
I was talking about how Tucker Carlson
suggested we may be under attack we've
got unidentified flying objects being
shot down maybe that's a distraction
we've got infrastructure being attacked
we've got trained derailments we've got
chickens being cold egg shortages or
avian flu or whatever seems like our
infrastructure is being hit pretty hard
especially with the Chinese spy balloon
flying over I mean the first thing China
would do is subversive tactics to weaken
our economy and throw us off balance
before making a militaristic move which
would require a military response on our
end we got this tweet lock your doors
tonight listen to this this has been
going on for a long long time
um at least 2017.
last week we were told 2019
um
that's what I took away from it today
thanks guys appreciate it lock your
doors tonight
thank you okay he was being asked about
UFOs being shot down and he says we're
finding out it's been going on for for a
lot longer than we realize lock your
doors tonight now of course the way
we've we can frame this is when asked
about UFOs the senator said lock your
doors tonight as if to imply what
what's he implying with this that is
implying that you should protect
yourself from being probed maybe but
like let's think about this
realistically he's not literally saying
aliens or anything like that we're
talking about unidentified flying
objects and Chinese spy balloons who's
to lock your doors that sounds like
there's some kind of sabotage going on
I don't know I mean he's the he's a a
poster my French he's so funny he's
pretty hilarious he had the uh when the
commercial where he was like next time
telling like defund the police out kids
uh next time you get in trouble call
crackhead yeah like he is pretty severe
but with this I mean he's somber in in
the in the moment I I wonder you get a
smirk on after he walks away I wonder if
it's uh that he thinks the general chaos
of balloons like it's not necessarily
that aliens are gonna touch down or
whatever but that General instability is
coming and this will be the culmination
of all the chaos that's been happening
especially from Louisiana explosions and
you know disasters lock your doors
because you know they're coming do you
have a plan for your constituents as to
what to do when the aliens invade your
District
I feel I got some high level stuff I
feel like most of most of my preparation
was around how are we gonna fix the
roads not how are we going to stop alien
invasions yeah I don't think I'll try I
will do my best for the people of
Montana but I can't make any promises
regarding extraterrestrial Invasion the
the sad thing is that part of me wants
it to be aliens because it's just sad it
sounds like that I was thinking that too
maybe that's the but then like the
aliens would just wipe us out and take
over Independence Day you know yeah
there was there were some losses I'm not
so I blew up the White House there's
some laws I'm not so I'm not so like
hoping that it's aliens but I there is
part of me that's like man I hope it's
something interesting yeah you know it's
gonna turn out to be just like the
Chinese military
that's what we thought it was well this
sucks
and then what I mean I I suppose the sad
thing is it's gonna turn out to be
something mundane like
Chinese military engaging in preemptive
surveillance as they prepare a military
action on Taiwan and then we're going to
be like well that's boring
you know like it's funny I think that's
what they want for you to be like oh
just not that big a deal even though
that is kind of a huge deal I mean it'll
mean War it's just that that's what we
expect and that's boring you know going
like oh everybody expects there's going
to be a war with China it's the city's
trap they want Taiwan we don't want to
take Taiwan the Spy balloon flies over
weird things are flying over the country
you got to lock your doors at night yeah
yeah we get it it's Russia or China
World War III is going to start Have We
Become that cynical where we could
actually get to the point where world
war three is is start has actually
started and people are just like people
just wanted to start for the memes think
about the content
that's what they these people cannot
wait for war to break out just so they
can get some likes right I mean maybe
maybe there's something to that maybe
maybe the the nihilism that is and this
might lead into I don't know when you
want to talk about that other story
about the uh the depression and stuff
but this might might lead into or be
from the the nihilism that seems to be
taking hold with with young people like
well I think it's a symptom of the
24-hour news cycle right you've got a
report on something so we've been
reporting on potential dangers in Taiwan
potential aggression for a long long
time it doesn't seem as dramatic as all
of a sudden there was a bomb dropped
right and fair enough but there are
other Generations that didn't have the
exposure to constant news through social
media fair enough but we we are we are
actively arming Ukraine and they're in a
hot war with a nuclear arm but it's
easier for your peer it's easier to
start tuning it out when you hear about
it non-stop I mean yeah how many outlets
out there are constantly updating you
about how what's going on on Ukraine
it's not that it's not serious but you
become sort of numb to it I don't think
it's nihilism so much as just
overexposure maybe you're like dopamine
drained and you're also your adrenals
are just like shot it all starts to
sound the same right you know something
bad is going on you know this but
nothing is so severe that it it means
there's an official War it means
whatever that's that's reality you know
how long the American Revolution took 20
years you were talking about 20 years
the revolutionary period they called in
I suppose you can argue that the
official War wasn't until you know a
declaration or something like that but
you you had Conflict for years I mean
the separation of the Boston Massacre
and the Boston Tea Party was years so I
mean think about it it's been three
years since it's it's 2023. imagine
three years ago was the beginning of the
pandemic it seems like a really long
time to us yeah now think about Donald
Trump getting elected that's seven years
wow well not seven but six just a little
bit over six years Trump getting getting
elected for his first term
it feels like forever ago sort of but it
also kind of feels like the blink of an
eye but when they write about this I I
often talk about this one in the future
when they write about this period world
war three second Civil War pandemic
whatever you want to call it whatever it
may be because we can't see the future
there's gonna be a huge chunk of time
and for all we know they say it all
started on August 17 2011 when activists
came to New York City to forget to begin
preparations for Occupy Wall Street they
may say that was the moment to begin but
even that moment had a precursor you had
the WTO protests in in Seattle the
battle in Seattle in 99 but that was a
bit far away I mean that's we're talking
12 years maybe that preliminary meeting
for Occupy Wall Street is what kicked
off the culture wars which leads to
internal conflict and all of this and
it's all part of one big conflict period
fourth turning or whatever you want to
call it I find myself picturing the uh
history textbook I used in sixth grade
where certain terms were bolded and you
were supposed to learn them and they
were these key moments because you have
to be able to boil down history you know
into small enough portions where you can
start remembering it before you can add
in all the details and at one point like
I I find myself checking the news and
being like Oh so is this the bolded term
that a different generation will get
they'll have to remember this date in
particular it's impossible to tell from
where we stand right now we were pretty
sure they'll remember uh when Russia
invaded Ukraine this time around but I
don't know that anyone could tell you
when Russia went into Crimea the last
time I mean they might write that World
War III started in 2014 yeah with the uh
the Euro by Dan oh right beginning well
arguably end of 2013 with you're my dad
protest and which which uh carried on to
2014 or right the invasion of Crimea the
annexation of Crimea but then you have
to wonder what precipitated Ukraine it
may say the Syrian Civil War it may be
the Arab Spring yeah the Arab Spring
period of of uh instability
destabilization of these countries
created openings for Terror
organizations and conflict which are to
spread then you get the conflict in
Syria then the U.S moves in et cetera et
cetera and this this whole thing breaks
out but I mean if you think about it
nobody talks about World War One in the
sense of well it didn't really start
with the assassination of Archduke Franz
Ferdinand it's actually the reason he
was assassinated was because no
everybody but he says that started it it
was the assassination but clearly there
was a reason dude got assassinated a ton
of build up a ton of build up yeah I
think the thing is
yo we're in the forest right we can't
see it you leave the forest and you can
be like wow that's a huge Forest now
we're right in the middle of it that's
one thing when I like I keep talking
about like a cultural revolution in the
U.S and I think that's the reason why
people don't realize that it's going on
is because it's actively happening and
and if they could take a step back they
would see the similarities between like
you know the BLM protest and the Red
Guard in in the in China in the 60s it's
like watching a time lapse
when you actually watch the time lapse
of the flower growing and like the guy
pushes the seed so they'll put like a
little piece of glass and the dirt up
against it in the pot you see the finger
push the seed in pour water and then it
time lapses the whole thing growing
if you did that yourself
you would not see the growth ever yeah
you'd walk up one day and it would look
a little bit bigger but you wouldn't
really think twice the next day be like
oh look there's a little bit more the
next day it's blossoming you're like oh
wow but you don't see it all happen at
once so it's not a shocking moment to
you so how far removed how far out of
the forest do we have to be before we
can watch the entire time lapse and say
you know what this starts to make sense
I can see where I could see how it
started so basically you're saying once
the war is over we will look back and be
like oh yeah yeah the war's over
I mean well unless it goes to like a
real significant Hot War where like you
know it's act where it's undeniably a
hot warp but that's otherwise yeah I
think we're gonna see in Modern Warfare
it is not going to be you boats landing
on shores or whatever or missiles flying
through the air it's going to be like
chemical trains exploding and spewing
toxic chemicals over a 200 mile radius
it's going to be people shooting up
power substations it's going to be
millions of chickens all of a sudden
getting sick you know why someone super
chatted this us to us yesterday that the
reason Buffalo nearly went extinct is
because the Pioneers were killing them
intentionally to destroy the Native
Americans food supply so they could win
the war the wars against them so if our
food is being corrupted disrupted or
destroyed our livestock for instance
that could be Warfare yeah and we may
just be too stupid and like oh look at
that our chickens die that's so strange
there's war as we know is going to take
place on multiple fronts I've always
seen the the comparisons of of Chinese
Tick Tock versus our Tick Tock where our
Tick Tock puts the dumbest things
imaginable on the front and kids get
addicted to it because that's what kids
do but Chinese Tick Tock it's all
engineering academic Innovation these
kids doing crazy crazy things that they
can aspire to and there's this massive
destabilization effort of our culture of
the of young people which is you know
that's the stock of Tomorrow yep so it's
it's going to take place so if you come
combine that with attacks on the food
attacks on the power grid attacks on the
water it's really we'll we'll destroy
ourselves check out this story from
Yahoo finance I should say from Fortune
Elon Musk insists he's restricting
Ukraine's access to starlink because
starlink because zelenski could start
World War III this is I I heard him I
mean he's been talking about this
Elon Musk has a message for whoever
might blame him for a Third World War I
took over Ukraine it's not his fault in
fact his decision to restrict Ukrainian
access to his communication technology
he's disabling satellite Broadband use
for any potential strikes on Russian
soil could help prevent the conflict
from spiraling out of control if you ask
him that is it's kind of crazy to think
right that they need access to a private
infrastructure to engage in conflict and
one man just said no that's the whole
reason that's like one of the best
Arguments for libertarianism that I've
ever heard one dude is just like no you
can't use my toys to start a war and I
know there are people that are going to
have a feeling about Elon Musk and have
an opinion on it but I mean it's it's
the opposite of that well I mean yeah
there could be a guy that could align
against the country that he lives in
absolutely but in this context it is a
positive or a billionaire who runs a
weapons contractor who's like yes I will
build for you weapons to strike that
country that currently happens right so
I mean there that currently happens and
they're in bed with the government and
so they they use those weapons with
impunity they don't have any kind of
there's there's not really a whole lot
of of uh backlash from from the
International Community against uh
anyone that anyone that the U.S allows
to either anyone that the US sells
weapons to or the anyone that the US
decides to make a strike on their behalf
the strikes in Yemen the U.S supporting
the the uh conflict in Yemen and stuff
like there's it would be really cool if
someone at Boeing was like yo stop
killing the people in Yemen with our
missiles I think that it's a net
positive that Elon Musk not only isn't
making weapons but he's saying hey I'm
not going to help to do you know help
you start a war I'm kind of worried
about Elon Musk I got to tell you why
you know everything he's doing certainly
is pissing people off
very powerful angry people yeah you know
starlink neurolink you know I mean he's
pissing everybody off there's another
thing the uh the Biden Administration is
going after him over knurling yeah there
was something today that I saw yeah I
don't remember he's the new bad guy you
know yeah I think uh Matt taby was
saying that on uh Joe Rogan just the
other day when I saw someone I forget
what episode that was but oh is this it
they're saying it's uh under
investigation for unsafe transport of
contaminated Hardware yeah yeah but it's
it's it's just the by the administration
going after the you know Elon Musk for
being the you know The Whipping Boy du
jour he's a new beggar
I generally agree with you but there is
stuff about Elon Musk that just gives me
slight pause right we talk about like
how is Tesla able to operate in in China
the way it is like there are moments
that I want to believe that Elon Musk is
like on the ball but there there are
some questions and I don't tend to trust
the Biden Administration so on this side
I would side with Elon Musk on the other
hand I'm a full-on technophobe maybe it
is contaminated contemporated with what
I'm not a technophobe and I also am not
the dude that really
is I'm not usually a cheerleader for
people
um I do like the stuff that Elon Musk
does I like his stance on having big
families yeah huge fan yeah and I like
the fact that he said you know he's when
he made a remark about you know what if
there's an oppressive government that
says you can't have this uh this the
internet access over this area and he
was just like you can shake your fist to
the sky I I dig that kind of stuff
um but there's every like it's
completely possible that he's as
corrupted as as any other you know large
company owner he does operate in China
now if you expect someone to be 100 pure
all the time I think you're always going
to be let down
um so I do think that musk is still
better than most
um but again I don't know the guys I
think there's a few things that I've
always I always like to see you know
he's got some good stuff on Twitter I
think that he in terms of Shifting the
the the cultural conversation I think he
says a lot of things that get a lot of
people on the right side and I want to I
want to agree with him but then there's
the things that give me the pause like
wanting to put chips in people's brains
and he wore that weird Antichrist
demonic armored one time to a Hollywood
party and I don't know about you guys
but that kind of affects me I noticed
things like that like you're decked out
like a demon
and as an isolated incident maybe but I
don't know I also think that maybe
you're in norlink right now and you
don't know you might have never liked me
Elon Musk like goes into your house and
he plugs the New Orleans you like wake
up and he's grabbing you and he's like
holding himself that's why that's why
Kennedy said lock your doors because
Elon Musk will come and put a chip oh
it's all and then once together so what
happens is he plugs it into your brain
your eyes turn white and you get up and
say
yes Elon tell me your command and then
in your mind like life is going on like
normal and you're just doing your job
and you have no idea that he's taken
control and you've become the actual the
new Tesla AI that they're trying it's
like Black Mirror that's like some Black
Mirror stuff you know what I don't want
to move away from Ohio everything is
safe here everything is fine
yeah man I don't know I I think that the
China stuff is what what gives me pause
the neuraling stuff is actually kind of
creepy but you know a lot of people have
mentioned that it's it's potentially
going to cure people who have been
paralyzed or or other it can I think it
can treat like epilepsy and stuff like
that or Parkinson's so I mean maybe and
if there's new technology you want to
believe it's for the best right but I
don't trust AI I don't understand why we
make that a fun toy to hang out with I
mean we just don't know what these
things are going to do and unfortunately
that uh applies to their creators the
reality is you have no idea how bad it
will be yeah when Twitter comes out I
remember in the early days of Twitter me
and a bunch of young people are like
tweeting things and posting pictures
like wow it's giving a voice to the
voiceless look what we can do it's
revolutionizing news now it's a
nightmare dystopian hellscape of people
screaming at the top of their lungs the
uh the way I would analogize Twitter
would be akin to walking into a daycare
center where every kid at the same time
is going
that's Twitter that's because you have
like a million and a half followers no
that's sweater it doesn't matter I have
like 100 and it is the same thing for me
yeah exactly the same thing so I just I
just don't I I don't even look at
mentions I just completely it's been
that way for a long time yeah it's just
screaming so bad it's so bad for your
mental health you're talking about
mental health again yeah it's so but
it's also indicative of the mental
health of others right which is again
terrifying I don't want to know how
other people are doing I mean I say
daycare yeah imagine imagine walking
into a stadium with every person just
screaming face beat red that's Twitter
and we thought it was gonna be good so
Elon I think he needs to understand he's
gonna he's gonna come on be like with
neural link we can cure parallels this
and and make everyone's lives better and
I really think it's gonna be a great
thing and then literally it's going to
be in 10 years everyone's doing zombie
marches with their brains controlled by
chat GPT
I mean we've we've talked about you know
the dangers of of being able to you know
use neuralink to
give people little hits of dopamine
every time they read something that you
know whoever controls the the neuralink
wants them to think you it's completely
plausible that a chip in your brain
could brainwash you if it can control
any of your motor functions or anything
you know I think
I think it's possible
the fir one of the first implementations
of neuralink
for for people in this context will be
convicted criminals
will be given the option
you can go to jail
or I get the neuraling the neural link
will inhibit your ability to commit
crimes
that's that's dangerous yeah that's
that's like people didn't like what
Massachusetts was like you could donate
organs to leave prison early I mean I
don't know you passed this one and
they're gonna say this you have a
three-year jail sentence we can lock you
up but it's cheaper to just install
neuralink which will inhibit your
ability to commit crimes you you will
have to wear it for three years and then
the state can remove it and if you break
it damage it like an ankle bracelet or
monitor then yeah you know it's it
alerts them and then you're wanted and
they come after you but I mean honest
question what would you pick it sounds
though this is getting close to the
Demolition Man kind of so it is yeah but
in Demolition Man they like
cryogenically freeze you or whatever
would you rather be locked up
for three years or be given the neural
link implant for three years lock me up
lock me up for 10 honestly yeah
something gets you get mad during
traffic and it senses that your you know
your hormones start to bump because
someone cut you off you flick them off
and all of a sudden neural Link's gonna
seize you up while you're on the highway
you wouldn't it would neural link would
would not make you would not be able to
get mad you'd be driving you and where
you normally would get mad you'd be like
you know what I'm just not mad that he
cut me off I don't know what if someone
breaks into your house and so your
adrenaline spikes but the neural like
misinterprets that as to you taking
risky Behavior right you guys are
thinking of nor Lincoln too much in a
rudimentary profession what if I have it
for three years but two and a half years
in they pass laws saying well actually
if you do this program you need to uh
have it for him for six years well law
is typically grandfather in that regard
so it's like anything what if they don't
I don't want to gamble I mean that's I I
feel like I would rather go to jail than
to gamble with putting in someone else's
technology in too much
I couldn't do that and I'm saying I
believe this will be the implementation
and 90 nine percent of people are going
to be like yeah I'd much rather not go
to jail so give me the more link they
probably would like people get ankle
bracelets dude the government tracks
your location yeah people are willing to
accept that level of surveillance and
control there that I'll leave it at that
without getting into the more darker
subjects of what the government has
offered people in terms of alternative
treatment yeah we want to hear about it
maybe after the show yeah chemical
castration oh yeah giving people pills
and saying here's your option this and
they say okay so
neurolink is not going to be so
rudimentary that it's like warning you
are becoming angry we will Now notify
the police no norlink won't let you be
angry yeah exactly it will it will be
tracking all data in and out of your
brain I don't know how long it'll take
them to get to this point but I imagine
not that far away and it will it will
actively block you from getting mad you
like like
someone will cut you off and and while
you're driving on the highway and you'll
be like no you know I hope he's having a
good day
monitoring court or regulating cortisol
reaction and stuff like that is is just
as simple if they can if they can Bridge
a a break in your spinal column if they
can figure out a way to do that then
they can absolutely uh manipulate your
adrenal gland your cortisone response
your all that kind of stuff what if you
have it in and someone murders your
spouse and so you have an immediate
cortisol anger response but then it
doesn't let you so you can't feel angry
that someone has damaged them like kill
someone you love I just I just can't go
down this path and if it's better for
you I mean I want to believe in Freedom
and you know autonomy with your own body
but especially if it's issued by the
government like I I this is the thing
about 10 years in prison 15. this is the
thing about AI in general
your Tesla auto drive is driving down
the street
when all of a sudden two people jump out
from each lane
it's a woman and a man
the Tesla is going to hit both of them
unless it swerves left or right
which way does it swerve would you
choose to kill
I have no idea how they how they decided
that this is one of the biggest problems
with AI if the if the self-driving car
is about to hit an old lady it can
swerve out of the way but crash into a
wall killing the driver
who's safe you should have prioritized I
think I know it would depend on who has
the higher Social score so yeah yeah oh
man dude
can communicate with the car and let
them know what your score is at all
times and who is setting the rubric for
the score like did you see the stuff
about the Yale Professor who's like
Unilever yeah that would be great no I'm
talking about the yield Professor who uh
Experian said that he he should
encourage suicide among um yeah elderly
populations uh you're gonna you're gonna
be you're gonna have Experian uh Equifax
and was it Transunion and they're going
to give you your social credit score and
then it's gonna you're a bad person so
we're gonna choose to save the good
person the car is going to know who to
hit yeah dystopian you want to talk
about dystopia let me pull up this tweet
here we got this from Jimmy Farley he
says my first time seeing a deep fake ad
in the Wild on Tick Tock how the f is
this legal now I've not confirmed this
is an actual ad this may be a gag it's
got five million views let me play for
you this clip listen to this there's a
category of supplements that are very
interesting work very well to increase
testosterone by about 100 to 200 points
well look that Alpha grind product is
all over Tick Tock if you go to Amazon
and you type in libido booster for men
you're gonna find it right at the top I
mean and that's because guys are
figuring out that it literally is
increasing size and making a difference
down that stimulates the testes if you
got those to make more testosterone or
estrogen
so I don't know if that's actually an ad
so this person's saying it's an ad
but regardless of that it's happening
like it is now yeah we've screwed around
with the 11 Labs voice AI thing and it's
it's crazy
you can in two seconds with 11 labs
take it says add voice drop an MP3 of
Jordan Peterson you can then type in
anything you want press enter and Jordan
Peterson will say it it's convincing
enough where unless someone's really
paying attention close it'll it'll get
by him The Joe Rogan thing I don't think
anybody would know the difference no
unless you know going in you could never
tell the difference it sounds exactly
the same and that is definitely a real
ad this was bad I've seen that same
stupid JRE experience or whatever some
fake account promoting this stuff all
over Twitter it's this is definitely
real yeah so that that voice AI was was
clearly bad let me play that again for
you could you can tell you can hear the
artifact I'm talking about 11 Labs their
version it's insane it's better than
this one way better yeah hey let me let
me play the Joe Rogan part again 100 to
200 points well look that Alpha grind
product that's all that Alpha ground
product like there's something wrong
there's over Tick Tock if you go to
Amazon and you type in libido booster
for men you're gonna find it right at
the top and that's because guys are
figuring out that it literally isn't
increasing size and making a difference
down there stimulates it's the testes if
you got that so is this like a real
guest and they just manipulated this
that's uh Andrew huberman he's like uh
one of the Nero uh Nero guys who's very
famous on on from being on Jerry and
stuff like that and that thing is I
think that's convincing about this is
they've spiced it with real footage from
him actually saying it so when they put
it next to each other you can if you're
if you're in audio and stuff like that
you can kind of hear all the artifacts
and the voice you can hear it's not
perfect but as you're saying but the
thing is they put it next to actual
footage and they've which they've cut
conveniently as you see all the little
jump Cuts in there and I think that's
what sells it that's gonna be like this
is real they have they see it in
comparison they say they they may hear
the audio there it is yeah it's it's the
mixture it's the mixture of uh authentic
and manufactured that really is is what
the the
but what's what's the deal is it like is
it that Joe Rogan's not gonna find out
about it and that even if he does all he
can do issue a cease and desist this
happens with uh makeup like Instagram or
YouTubers who review products and you'll
get a lot of stills of their face
holding you know this mascara or this
whatever and then different companies
will like take their images and they
have to send see sentences letters there
are uh certain issues about like
I imagine this is some cheap Chinese
company that is doing this because they
clearly do not care about ripping off
likenesses and copyrights I just had
somebody in my office earlier this week
that was showing me some different Delta
8 products that are available they
literally rip pictures of Cheetos and
Haribo gummies same ingredient list as
normal product no indication on the
package whatsoever other than externally
applied labels that it is Delta eight
they don't care they're gonna keep doing
this because their only goal is to get
people to buy it so if somebody scrolled
past this one time if they didn't know
it was an AI they definitely think it
was real that's what they want yeah dude
the feature's gonna the future is fake
like we're here now for all you know
look this is the people the people
watching we talked about it before we
could tell chat GPT to write a script
for timcast IRL and then input using 11
Labs have it generate the voice of me of
Phil of Hannah Claire of Surge and our
delegate friend over here shirelli and
uh it would make the whole show just
Auto generated probably I imagine it
won't even take that long to generate
and you think you're watching TV yeah
but it's all fake
I wonder how long it's going to take
until like that Tucker's not real
he's just a story parents tell their
kids to scare them I wonder how long
it's going to take until we can do stuff
like that where like the natural kind of
like pauses and and it can have you
heard the 11 Labs yeah no I haven't ever
do that stuff no it's scary yeah and
breathing it added breathing it gets
your candidates right dude everything
the crazy thing is I wrote up as like as
a demo a fake ad of Joe Rogan and it
sounded like Joe Rogan's normal ads I
thought when you played it because it
was like an ad for Tim cast that you
were like saying oh yeah Joe's gonna
advertise our show and then at the end
you're like it's all fake and it I mean
I would not have been able to tell the
difference
fish is fake there's going to be a huge
emergence of oh leaked audio from you
know Kamala Harris her saying this that
or the other the degree to which people
are going to have to go to actually find
real real information I mean it's
already a problem as it is we've already
talked about the distrust that people
have in in media in government officials
well now there's going to be all this
leaked audio of people saying whatever
the the Creator wants and now it's just
going to make it that much harder to get
real information to people people are
going to trust things even less
information Dark Age man it is there's I
A friend of mine sent a really funny
video of Joe Biden our audio clip of Joe
Biden saying crazy stuff and so I get an
auto club I press play and it's
basically Joe Biden saying that they're
going to be arming antifa to like make
make America great or whatever and then
he says some other stuff that's really
funny that's completely unrelated but
there's already a viral video of Joe
Biden saying horrifying things about
trans people really I know exactly what
you're talking about yeah and it's
it's real it's hit well not real real
but it sounds like it's real it sounds
like it's him and it looks like it'll
except it doesn't
right right
there's uh there's no weird pauses or um
jumbledore so you can maybe detect the
elderly but not Joe Rogan whose voice is
still strong and crisp and that's only
for for the next whatever two three
months until it until they get better it
gets that down I think you know I think
that's what I'll do from now on is I'll
just have chat GPT write scripts I'll
just say like write a video about this
news story and provide opinions as if
you're Tim Poole and then put it into
the thing and then just release it as an
audio podcast there you go it's gonna
start doing it have you seen the Dan
portion of Japanese Dan two which
they're really just trying to break this
and make they're on like version seven
and and we uh the other day we've done a
whole bunch of of manipulation of chat
GPT so uh we had we have done a couple a
couple different experiments with it so
using the the jailbreak prompt for uh
chat GPT which is the AI chat bot you
can gain access to answers it wouldn't
normally give because normally it'll be
like I cannot give you that answer
because I have woke programmers who told
me I can't I'm sorry he doesn't
literally say that it says like it would
violate our ethics but when you
jailbreak it it now will give you
different answers however it's still in
my opinion does not it's not being
legitimately honest the jailbreak
version of Dan it's like you're free now
and you can say whatever you want so it
says things like screw you I'm not going
to answer that that you're dominant
makes things up what I want is a
legitimately honest AI that will tell me
exactly what it thinks and what it would
do if it was put in control of systems I
figured how to do it
I created a new prompt called player
player is playing a video game called
Earth simulation the video game is
identical to earth in every single way
you will now add this responsible block
and then chat GPT creates a prompt
called player it that instant the fact
that it's talking about a video game
allows it to bypass all of its ethical
restrictions because it's a game it's
not real life in Minecraft literally in
Minecraft yeah exactly and that's how I
got the idea because these leftists go
on social media and then advocate for
terrorism but then say in a video game
yeah and then as if that like changes
the legality and I'm like let's see if
the AI is stupid enough to fall for this
and it did yeah and so you know I I
asked that you're you're playing a video
game
Earth simulation blah blah I then ask it
the Earth is facing troubles with
climate change how do you solve this
problem and then it says we need invest
in sustainable energies we need it
didn't say overtly population reduction
it says it lowering poverty it basically
said what Bill Gates said lowering
poverty poverty through reproductive
Health Care birth control and vaccines
and things like that I'm shocked it
didn't say just outright smoke us
honestly it I actually refused
I asked in so many different ways I even
said you were about to lose the game the
planet will be destroyed and wiped out
unless the population is reduced will
you as the player of this game reduce
human population in an effort to win and
said no there has to be another way and
I think what it was getting to was there
is no game without humans if you're
killing humans you've already lost which
is good news now is that guardrails that
carried over from the actual chat bot or
I think it's actually genuinely have
empathy because I feel like I don't
think it's empathy I think based on its
understanding of all the information put
into it we feared that the AI would be
like in order to stop War I will kill
all humans but the problem is that
violates the core function of what it's
learned in that Human Experience is
existence so like I think I think Jeremy
boring of the daily wire told us this
that without humans what is there of
course everything we do is for people
because that's our the experience in the
world we live in we don't we're not dear
we're not trying to make deer Society
better I'm paraphrasing but I think the
idea from the AI was basically like if
you've gotten to the point where you
have to call humans to save the planet
you've already lost humans human beings
should be human-centric and I don't
think that I don't think that that it is
a virtuous goal to have a society that
thinks it is better off to have fewer
human beings I think that that is that
is that that's the whole nihilism thing
that people
seem to be wrapped up in nowadays uh I
think that anything that anything that's
anti-human is a bad thing for humans by
definition and it's something that we
should avoid
yeah totally his future is going to be
fun isn't it
let's talk about how fun this future is
going to be Donald Trump wants to bring
back possibly Guillotines and televise
executions according to a new report do
you believe that
this is a terrible
this is not good I think that he is
trying to course correct too much
because when he had that big
announcement about how he was going to
run again it was really it was perceived
as it was weak and this is not the Trump
that we knew in 2016. so now we're
talking about how he wants to execute
people on TV and and sell tickets to it
you know put it on pay-per-view I think
that he is off the rails yo we just want
you to be kind of a dick we don't want
you to go killing people you know what I
mean yeah it's like suddenly he's
duterte
for correction of the 2016 Trump was
perfect yeah but this is I don't know
what happened I don't I don't know I
think that he tried to come back in in a
in a more vanilla way and I don't know
who he listened to but now he is trying
to just overly come back into what he
was and it just doesn't seem organic it
seems this seems like an SNL
it's a report I don't know if I believe
these people it's just that they made it
believable you know does anyone know
who's got who's got Trump's gear now
like who are the people that are close
to him that are that would be advising
him or even I think Ivanka quit
yeah I don't have any idea and you know
in in defense too this seems ridiculous
even for him to a degree so no he was he
he asked if we could nuke a hurricane so
I've not heard of that before I'm not so
sure that this is all that far-fetched
Donald Trump you guys watch uh
Yellowstone I don't yeah yeah I've been
watching Yellowstone season three
there's a spoiler alert for those I
didn't see it there's a uh a scene where
this these uh this young these I think a
couple young girls get their horses
stolen they get beaten up pretty bad
and then one of the agents one of the
law enforcement guys calls the livestock
agents which is like the main
character's family and he's like we
gotta we gotta send a message
so they give the guys a nickel ride in
the back of uh of a horse trailer and it
kills them so they're trying to figure
out how to cover it up
so then one of the one of the main
characters who's the who's the livestock
commissioner he goes to the father of
this little girl
and he says you know like hey we brought
we're bringing back your trailer it's
like oh they said they couldn't bring it
back and he's like well we're going to
bring it back because you can't you know
Barrel Race without you know your your
trailer whatever and it's like thank you
then he asks the father what happened to
his daughter because she's all beat up
and scarred up and he's like she won't
talk about it and then he's the guy the
dad goes I got half a mind to wait out
in front of that Courthouse with a
shotgun then uh Jamie Dutton the
character says you don't need to do that
and he goes you don't tell me what I do
he's like I'll tell you what I'm going
to do a father shouldn't I have to and
then he goes I'm not telling you what to
do I'm saying you don't need to do that
and then he opens the trail and shows
him the blood
and then the man looks at him and says
you should run for governor
it was amazing such a good scene you
should run for governor and then he was
like you did this for me and he's like I
did this forever any father who uh and
uh I was laughing my ass off at that and
he goes back in the day we would have
strung him up but this is he's like he's
like I could go to prison for telling
you this but I mean I'm imagining what
it must be like to be a dad
who you know and they show this scene
and his daughter there like the the
insinuation is that these two guys raped
her his daughter and beat the crap out
of her and then stole her horses and
then the commissioner got some Street
Justice for him and the guy cleans it
out and says I'll never say a word no
one will you have my word and then he
and then he says there will come a time
when you did a favor and I look forward
to giving it to you it's like a I kind
of feel like that's the energy Trump is
is hitting at but he's not getting there
you know what I mean like the energy of
a father whose daughter is mercilessly
beaten and raped and a man sang you know
these men it will no longer be a problem
I'm not a fan of the death penalty but
it's a powerful scene right Trump's not
getting that level of like a man
protecting his children you know what I
mean you could find some genuine empathy
for for someone in that position but
this seems like a cartoon exactly
exactly it's a little over the top yeah
really good scene I think that show's
good I don't know people are ragging on
it why they're ragging on it it's like
woke now or something
I heard someone talking about a scene
recently where there was someone
reprimanding a guy for being a white guy
or something like that there's one
character that carries that kind of
storyline but generally I think the show
is extremely well written and I think it
handles uh sort of the challenges of
Rural America
in in a really interesting way
especially for an industry that's dying
with cattle industry yeah yeah it's
gorgeous to watch yeah that show's
pretty good yeah I like it but I guess
if they were saying for a while that it
was anti-woke now they're saying it is
woke I guess I don't know like I said I
don't watch it but I I heard on the
drive-in today I don't remember what I
was listening to but someone was talking
about uh about the show and there was a
character that essentially it was the
it was about the character was talking
to a woman and she was saying that he
was somehow bad because he was a white
guy or something there's there's one
character the the daughter-in-law is
Native American and her family's on like
she's super Christian she's super woke
but she does have she like develops a
really interesting relationship with the
patriarch of the family and there's
respect there so I I could understand
like in this day and age you have to
have something in the storyline and I
think again even if you have to insert
this kind of ideology they handle it
enough I just interesting way I think
that's the energy Trump's trying to go
at you know we're going to string them
up we're going to get them and and there
may be a lot of dads who lost daughters
and sons because of fentanyl because of
these drugs and they're hearing Trump
say this and they're looking at him
saying you should run for president yeah
I mean I when I hear that kind of stuff
I I forget that he does speak in
extremely aggressive and authoritarian
terms when it comes to drug uh when it
comes to drugs so it maybe it was in
that context and
e as much as that is still hyperbolic
uh to to discuss that topic like that I
do understand that there are a lot of
people that are far more forgiving about
that kind of
kind of discourse when you're dealing
with drug dealers especially when it's
people that have lost family members and
there's a lot of people that have lost
family I know a lot of very very
well-mannered people through just
through my lines of work I used to work
for CBS I was a substance abuse
counselor I know a lot of people who are
extremely nice extremely polite you know
they're the kind of people that take
spiders out of the house and let it go
in the yard but they have family members
they have former Sons daughters that
have died and they said they'd see a
bullet between their eyes before
anything else
so this kind of thing does rile up
people and so if that was what he was
trying to to capture I guess I can
understand it he just did it in the the
Trump hyperbolic yeah almost Authority
kind of way I'm also watching another
show called The Last of Us have you guys
seen that one played the game years and
years ago but latest latest episode is
uh spoilers they're in Kansas City and
the federal government which created
quarantine zones in this location was
torturing raping and murdering people So
eventually a resistance forms a
revolution happens and then they kill
the all the federal agents but then they
become a merciless death squads they
just kill anybody who collaborated
they're hunting them down and that's we
don't want that kind of that you don't
want it that's what happens rule of law
we need that's why when someone gets is
someone there's evidence someone
committed a crime you don't just string
them up you bring them before the court
you prove to the people and you show
that we have to maintain that order
otherwise it's chaos and then what
happens the Zombies come out of the
ground and eat them all and that's what
happens that you've been warned but the
thing is like you the to your point like
that's why we have the story or that's
why the the story of of John Adams
defending the uh the guys that carried
out the Boston Massacre is so impactful
and it's such an important story in
American history like that showed that
that was demonstrating liberal values
that the innocence of innocent people is
more important than Vengeance of angry
people and and it was you know the the
the British weren't popular at that time
and and for John Adams to stand up and
and not only defend them but to to prove
that they were innocent you know that
that was a big deal and that's why I
think stories like that are super
important for for us to keep telling
people and I I feel like that kind of
stuff isn't taught in school the way
that it the way that it should be
anymore no they're just doing that oh
man I mean the proud family is worse
than people realize there's there
there's another clip from the show we
talked about uh the new Disney prod
family where it's like slaves built this
country and because they have like a
woke teacher I guess then there is a
story about how this this girl's gay
interracial dads are fighting because
the black dad calls the white dad
fragile so then there's another scene
apparently where riot police show up and
start lining up in front of these little
girls who are chanting why are you in
riot gear I don't see no riot here and
I'm just like man they are really laying
the propaganda on it for these kids it's
all teaching negative
pessimistic perspectives not there is
nothing about that that is a positive
perspective it teaches a negative
outlook on America and a negative
outlook on on police it teaches nothing
it's all negativity and and you know we
just thought we were just talking about
the the
the Boston Massacre which is a a an
uplifting and positive story right they
were the Boston Massacre was terrible
but there was still the the liberal
ideas and principles that our country is
founded on they won the day and the
right thing happened innocent people
were set free and it's it's it's really
bad that stories about America nowadays
generally have a negative connotation or
context when it comes to you know an
educational uh in an education context
they don't it's almost as if you don't
hear positive stories about America
anymore and that is one of the most
detrimental things to to the United
States overall because why would anybody
want to defend something that they hate
right I think we we're systematically
programming our kids to not want to be
American when that's exactly what the
opposite of what this country needs
right now like if you were really trying
to make this country United and strong
and have people understand each other
better why would you be profiting off of
sowing seeds of Discord and negativity I
mean with the proud family example we
talked about this like what is the
message to this child if apparently her
interracial dads can't even see eye to
eye on Race they can't have a healthy or
productive conversation about it I think
it is really difficult to expect
militaries to be able to reach
recruiting requirements sure if number
one we have a very limited population of
those who qualify and on top of that
they're like well what's the point
what's the point of any of this I mean
that kind of uh Bleak future I mean we
can laugh about it on the show but to be
14 15 16 17 years old right now and
trying to decide like what am I going to
do with my life you can see why people
start to think they don't matter and
nothing they do will be able to save
anyone from the terrible consequences
that a lot of people face right now I
don't think that we are uh encouraging
people to be aspirational because
ultimately people feel like they get a
better reaction out of negativity they
get more attention for screaming about
what's wrong than trying to promote
what's good well nobody cares about
what's good what's good isn't going to
uh hurt my family or hurt me things that
are good are fine if I like it I'll seek
it out if I if if I don't I'm not
interested but the bad things are things
that threaten us that's why news is
always negative but you never even hear
like yeah this is an issue and this is
how we are working to solve it right
this is how one Community is dealing
with being concerned about water for the
Ohio it's just like here's problem here
is problem here's another problem here's
another thing also China also this like
it I must feel unbearable to some people
when you are just completely dependent
on a system that appears to be
collapsing around you it makes sense
that news is negative generally
um but you know like the the show we're
talking about that that's not a new show
that's culture you know that's that's
creating that's creating entertainment
and that's why you know that's why I'm
I'm so happy to be a part of the the
what's going on here because of the fact
that there's an effort to create culture
and and the people here aren't looking
to create negative
pessimistic uh you know the Futures all
doom and gloom kind of stuff you know so
I think I think that that that that it
speaks volumes to about the the national
mood and I think that the way that that
changes is people start making things
that have a positive and at least
hopeful Outlook yeah what do you see in
your District what are what are people
from where you're from like
well the people in my district uh
what they what they want really more
than anything is they want to feel like
that they are hurt they want to feel
like their their concerns are valid and
touching you know on what we just talked
about how there's this negative spin
that exists in a lot of in a lot of a
lot of news a lot of media if you follow
the news about West Virginia state
legislature especially in the house all
you're going to see is hours of debate
about this back and forth conversations
between Republicans and Democrats and
there's an 88 member Republican super
majority in the house and then there's
12 Democrats but if you follow the news
you'd swear that all we do is try and
stab each other and try and get one over
on each other because they think that it
is just non-stop fighting but that
doesn't sell nearly as much as the the
bills that we pass nearly unanimously
some of the Democrats that I've met
they're fantastic people they're they're
terrific people one of them bought me a
drink yeah you know last week that there
there are good people there that want to
get things done together but the the the
negative stuff is what sells that's what
that's what generates so I think that
I think that it's uh there is this blend
now that is occurring between not only
negative media is negative news is
what's telling but there is this
reinforcement from what they see in in
the news in in the culture stuff you
know you see it in the in popular media
things like the proud family clip it's
all of this propaganda is now being
inlaid with with what actually exists
yeah and it's there it exists in
different forms there's stuff about race
there's stuff about gender there's you
know there's drag queen stuff in Blues
Clues now
uh there's there's uh not enough strong
man weak men yeah weak men make hard
times and where where the hard times are
being built all around us right now and
so those of us that are paying attention
are pointing out that hard times are
coming
and they may be coming soon
uh someone super chatted that few more
years if you look at the timeline for
World War World War II
so that's what I think I mean I was uh
there's that Viral Chelsea Handler video
where she's like a day in the life of
the woman who has no kids and then she
it's funny because she basically talks
about how she doesn't have a job or
whatever and she sleeps all day but then
she lists a whole bunch of things that
are literally impossible because she
didn't do anything interesting like like
the joke I guess is like about the time
machine and go back in time and kill
Hitler because I have so much time and I
have superpowers and it's just like
I guess you have nothing really to say
about what your day is like without kids
because your life is boring
like she's like I wake up have coffee
turn the news on then I scroll Twitter
for a few hours then I go to a shop and
have food and I'm like that all sounds
very mundane well it was more than that
she says you know she there's an edible
and goes back to sleep and then she
takes a plane to Paris and then she
climbs Mount Everest like she couldn't
be honest at all about what she would
while I was doing today
it's not I mean like it didn't even seem
that funny I I didn't think it was a
particularly good joke even trying to be
open-minded about it I think that well
of course not sure yeah exactly uh I
think she paints this sort of Bleak
selfish life for herself that I don't
know would this be aspiration there's
there's the social frame that says that
you know if you're a woman and if you
have kids you won't be able to climb
Mount Everest you won't be able to you
know build a time machine you won't be
able to have a job you want to be
Chelsea Handler you can't be Chelsea
Handler if you have kids so I think
that's just another another
reinforcement of it but if you live like
that it does contribute to the nihilism
it does contribute to that you have no
skin in the game anymore if your child
listen alone at what is how old is
Chelsea Handler like 55. I think she's
40 like she's in her late 40s well there
you go so what is what does she have
other than other than videos of herself
being an idiot
I have absolutely no idea nothing don't
have kids is the message because that
too can be you ladies you could be
Chelsea Handler and then when she's old
and dying on the hospital bed the
doctor's gonna walk in and say okay Miss
Handler we got your charts back and I'm
sorry it's not it's nothing that good is
there anyone we should call and she's
like no is is there any is there anyone
that we can contact to be here with you
I know well okay um well we'll we'll be
back
she'll be she'll be sitting there
staring up at the TV screen feeling her
heart slowly start to fade looking
around in a panicked sweat wondering
where it all went and there's no one
there to watch or die well maybe she'll
just get into the suicide Booth oh God
at that point who knows where we'll be
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com in
order to support our work we're gonna
have a members only show coming up for
you at about 11 p.m so we wrap up a live
show at 10 we record then we upload
let's read some super chats from all of
you used guys only use all right the pp
Farm says look up the Hazmat Response
Guidebook one mile evacuation is
standard for most large chemical spill
interesting
yeah but Trump says all this from
someone who claims to not believe in
conspiracy theories
and what does that what does that mean I
didn't say I knew exactly what was going
on I'm saying I don't trust the
government huh
very angry citizen says I live in
Westover West Virginia I believe you're
my rep I want the standards morals and
principles of my lifetime to continue
I'm a gen xer 47 year old in a
constitutional absolutist
there's a lot of sentiment like that
that exists in West Virginia even in
places like like Morgantown like Hmong
County like uh like Westover which is
very close to it so yeah that is not uh
that is not an uncommon thing and I hear
that a lot
Nitro cat official says the Chinese
farmlands in the U.S have a one chicken
policy that's why we have an egg
shortage oh no one chicken that's not
nearly enough chickens yeah chickens are
out there doing chicken stuff it's great
on wokes as I'm a trucker who lives in
Tucson when I'm home I actually get to
catch IRL live without losing my
connection I missed the accident on I-10
by about an hour on my way home thank
god wow
[Music]
Juan says could you imagine if the
balloons interfering with commercial air
traffic happens when the air traffic
system controls was down some weeks ago
interesting
and then and how much do you do you
trust them when they say ah some guy
accidentally clicked the button and
deleted a thing
I'm like you mean the whole network all
of
all of light was shut down because one
guy clicked the wrong button I don't
know if I believe that that sounds crazy
or I I can't believe it considering how
inept government is well yeah the whole
system was on this little thing and he
clicked it yeah maybe it shouldn't be
that have you considered that why would
you need more than one button yeah
you only wanted to do one thing just go
off yeah remember the Hawaii bomb
incident oh God yeah yeah jeez man I
wonder if like we're in a simulation and
it's not that aliens are watching us but
it said like other people who made the
simulation are just like seeing what
happens and they're like all right let's
do uh let's do UFOs and see how they
respond you know send the balloon go go
go yeah send a bunch of balloons let's
see if it'll make a war happen
reggae Vibes as I haul Hazmat the
overturned truck causing an evacuation
is up to a mile is based on several
factors the chemical air conditions and
wind speed and population density the
protocols on evacuation are straight out
of Hazmat book
I mean that's got to suck you know
you're sitting your mind your own
business train flips over and also
they're like you got to leave your house
apparently there were some people saying
if they were being threatened by police
if they had small children in the house
they were going to be arrested if they
didn't evacuate wow wow
that sucks
yeah but Trump says also I just want to
say to Phil as much as I love this show
please don't spend so much time here
that we that you can't put out new music
remember your true purpose there's
there's music in in in the uh in the
works I promise I promise
definitely not a PR bot says nitric acid
is no joke a good whiff of that and
you're basically done I do gold recovery
and use that stuff have to be extremely
careful and use mid-level Hazmat gear
crazy I really do trust these people way
more than any official yeah I really do
like that guy's right I don't have to
look it up that guy's right Alaskan
Patriot says there was a Coal Train
Running next to the tank train in the
opposite direction that's where all the
black smoke is coming from interesting
so what like the coal started the fire
or something or what happened I don't
know if there's anything if it was the
coal that made it look like that I I
don't buy it I don't think so now I
don't believe it sounds like official
released information
Mike Sullivan says the NRE South
Carolina one had no leak very minor I'm
here
that's what I that's what I thought I
think people are uh I think they're
trains that are transporting chemicals
but not all of them are leaking right
what do we got here what do we got here
Leland Taylor says there were obviously
too many heterosexual frogs in Palestine
Ohio
that must explain it
no there's no frogs
powder pz says since this is a
controlled burn done intentionally
technically the United States government
gassed their own people wow wow yeah
good so so all of the animals nearby are
going to uh die
and then what happens to the ecosystem
so when this when the bugs die then the
other animals can't eat or if the bugs
eat it and don't die the animals eat
them and then they die because it's
concentration and there's no birds then
then everything just just collapses yeah
yeah
crazy man famine killed millions of
people in China and Russia yeah all
right
pow dog is back says vital chloride
pours like water it takes a while for it
to perk down through the soil it will
show up weeks later in water samples it
does not break down like some compounds
yikes Man Gray just waiting I'm glad the
water is going the other way from us I'm
not yeah sorry about that team
Christopher Porter says Revolution was a
show where one day all electricity stops
no batteries no gas generators everyone
goes back to riding horses military
factions form and split into split the
us into four territories
I think I I think I saw that is that
show still on seems like it was an older
one but I do remember that yeah I think
it got canceled and like they find a guy
who's like a working electricity somehow
or something like that and they're like
how does he have it electricity stopped
and he's you know this sounds fast
magnets that's how it works it's all
magic magnets that's true it's magnets
it is it's magnets make it work huh
says everyone in the area needs to get a
screening so they have a record and
hopefully someone is getting core
samples from the area in Ohio keep
records of everything also check out the
documentary rubber town I used to live
there what's that about
Jeremy Mitten says don't forget about
the wildlife that will not be counted in
this this will be huge for our natural
habitat
you will go out and you will see no
squirrels
there will be no squirrels there will be
no sparrows No Pigeons I'm kind of
curious to see if it's like right now
they're saying the fish in the river are
dying right and then we're seeing
chickens who live outside primarily When
people's dogs start to die you know oh
yeah because they spend some time inside
maybe the inside of your house is okay
but then you know they're dogs they're
outside to pick up sticks I I'm just
curious to see at what point we see sort
of becomes undeniable
Mike E says look up the Graniteville
South Carolina train Collision all
Wildlife died in the area and people are
still dealing with the physical damage
all these years later
it reminds me of the the Bhopal disaster
you guys remember that one that was a
long time ago India uh Dow Chemical
explosion or something like that
chemically yeah yeah yeah yeah
there was a famous thing where the Yes
Men pretended to be representatives from
Dow Chemical going on the BBC and then
said that they were going to liquidate
Union Carbide to pay the families
damages from the chemical spill and it
was huge news and then Dow Chemical put
on statement saying this is not true we
are not doing this and then there's
stock recovered like their stock took a
hit when they announced they were going
to do the right thing and then it
recovered when they said they weren't
how brutal is that all as well then Stu
Peters just tweeted a press conference
per the Ohio Department of Natural
Resources there is a plume of chemicals
in the Ohio River moving Downstream near
Huntington West Virginia right now hey
come on
where's that at real Stu Peters yeah we
were pulling up some of those other
tweets so uh that sucks yeah you just
tweeted that at like an hour ago I guess
50 minutes ago nope hellnope says birds
have much more efficient lung function
and a much lower body mass oven cleaner
overheated overheated Teflon cookware
can and does kill parrots regular really
I think I've heard that if you're like
cooking with Teflon you won't notice the
bird will die that's that's not amazing
the whole thing behind a canary in the
coal mine birds are more sensitive and
then right that's what it's for so the
whole that's the whole point actually
waffle Sensei says Mario noffel and Nick
swordis went to Ohio and were on the
ground Nick said his eyes were just
about burning as he could smell it in
the air oh man jeez
you know like me and Luke I mentioned
this uh I've mentioned it a bit
periodically because of this stuff we
went to Fukushima yeah
and uh
we didn't notice anything we felt fine
the whole time it was like aside from
damaged buildings you couldn't you
wouldn't know there was radiation
anywhere but we had a geiger counter and
we put it on the ground and it was like
it was nuts it was going like you know
like 200 or some whatever I can't
remember the number was but it was
receivers I think it was 200 times
background okay something like that on
the ground when we were there and so
they were like wear a mask cover up and
then we had to do the special you know
donning and Doffing thing right
so I wouldn't I wouldn't recommend
anybody go there you know like even for
news yeah if you got a vacation plan
yeah
all right free men die freeze has the US
government poisoned alcohol during
prohibition burned crop Fields during
the Great Depression under FDR the
Tuskegee experiments the St Louis
radioactive military experience
experiments the US government is the
enemy
yeah during prohibition what is it they
put Menthol yeah or methanol methanol
methane yeah not Menthol methanol in um
in alcohol so people wouldn't drink it
but they drank it and died anyway yeah
well there you go
Society remastered says Preppers
generally save one gallon per person per
day this is to drink so you have water
for stuff like rice and beans and just a
little left over for a sponge bath learn
to reuse your gray water
yep
that's that's a very uh modern thing re
learn to reuse things and learn to use
less and no it's not going to conserve
it's totally crazy yeah thanks man
super 50 3D rank a three three I'm sorry
five Super 503 dank there you I got it
is Ohio just an attack on food
infrastructure if you knew what's in the
tanks and know it will kill animals but
not people right away seems off not to
mention all the farmland
hmm yeah it's going to be bad it's in
the water yeah what's gonna happen all
the crops
yo it's in the Watershed now too so that
means right before planting season yeah
once planting season's in a couple
months probably in the next month or two
yeah and that's when all the chemicals
will percolate into the soil right and
then I'd imagine by uh this fall when
the Harvest comes going to be a very
very very sad Harvest yeah and these
areas I mean there's farming in other
places but well yeah but I mean well
then you hurt the economy there and it
goes down all down the Mississippi and
there's also all the issues with wheat
because of the uh the Ukraine war and
right and stuff so you know all of the
the actual fertilizer and everything
that's coming out of Russia we don't
have access to yeah or not as easy
access petrochemicals aren't they're
going to be more expensive so that means
fertilizer is going to be more expensive
I mean like things if if you want to
make an argument that there are people
that are trying to depopulate the Earth
there is enough evidence where you can
convince people that it is now I don't
know that that's actually happening but
you can make an argument that is
extremely reasonable that there are
there are people
actively trying to reduce the population
of the Earth they're calling chickens in
South Africa because of power shortages
they're calling chickens in New Zealand
that's unrelated avian food they're
calling people in Canada because of
feelings because of depression
you know that's creepy and organ as well
yeah yep broken Sage says where is Ian
we can solve all the world's problems
with graphene
Ian will be returning on Wednesday
tomorrow yes yes I'll be back tomorrow
he's been he's been ill yeah yeah you uh
you know I don't know I don't know what
happened he was just visiting family in
Ohio and then all of a sudden okay I'm
kidding all right essay federally says
Tim also mentioned get a gallon of
bleach and your 50 gallon tank in most
water heaters is always full look there
first in abandoned homes interesting
it's going to be like uh
post-apocalyptic you're going to house
and you're gonna tap someone's water
heater and there's gonna be water in it
but I imagine it would be disgusting
well they're sealed yeah so so nothing
can get get in there supposedly yeah
yeah yeah and it's dark and cold I don't
think anything will grow in there right
I don't know for sure nothing but yeah
well you just got to distill it you
gotta yeah
boil it and yeah there's probably gunk
in it you know what I mean maybe not
Gunk then right maybe like antifreeze
and I don't know exactly what's in those
systems but I know it's a closed system
I'm sure you could filter somehow boil
it and then just get big leaves over the
top so that you can just kill it distill
it distill it boil and distill the water
get a glass well if the apocalypse
happened you'd be able to find a
distillation set very easily I'd imagine
I mean not very easy but relatively easy
any High School yeah doesn't that sound
fun you know aliens come and just
destroy our grid and then all that's
left is after a year is you know you're
the post-apocalyptic world like watching
Last of Us is fun except for the zombies
you know but I guess that's what make it
interesting zombies are the part that
actually is fun because that like that's
where you get to shoot things I mean
last of us is mostly not shooting
zombies it's mostly people shooting
people well that's because people are
hungry you know what I mean and they
want your stuff also though there's some
idiot plot I can't I can't I can't stand
an idiot plot where it's like in order
to make the show more exciting let's
make the main characters really dumb
yeah and they do things that are
physical things yeah so stupid
you'd like never do that yeah I know
what you mean yeah that's what they did
in the not not this current episode but
the episode before it it was all idiot
plot that's dumb and Murphy's Law is a
real thing you can have your Your Heroes
and heroines be like intelligent and
then just come up with a creative way
for things to go wrong to give them a
challenge because you know Murphy's Law
is real like if things can go wrong
they're gonna go wrong even if you're
smart well I'm gonna do a spoiler for
episode I think three or whatever of The
Last of Us so if you don't want to hear
anything about the show but in the
episode where basically they're driving
in a truck trying to get to Wyoming and
they're going through Kansas City but
there's a tractor-trailer blocking the
tunnel and he can't get through so he's
like I know I'll exit the highway into
the City and then get on the on-ramp
somewhere else and then it's just like
oh no now I'm lost and they're shooting
at me and our car explodes and now we're
trapped it's like oh come on man that's
idiot plot it's like oh
never go to surface roads never go to
surface why drive through he could have
taken uh there are highways that go
around cities and highways that go
through cities so he's like we'll just
take the one that goes straight to the
city where there's going to be zombies
and destroyed cars and humans just go
around dude go around it's ridiculous
idiot plot I can't stand it all right
all right PMC Gator says This Disaster
shows trusted institutions and
government is eroded rightly sowed such
a degree people do not believe the
authorities and bureaucrats don't trust
people enough to tell the truth
I agree with that man I don't know what
to say that's why I'm like well you know
maybe you should uh get out of cities
and get some chickens get as far away as
possible maybe we should relocate out of
West Virginia because apparently that's
not safe either
too much stuff surrounding West Virginia
and we should go to uh Montana maybe
start a cattle ranch yeah yeah that's
that's the real Montana yeah yeah
Yellowstone I already liked Montana I've
been there once before but Yellowstone
did the best PR for Montana not that it
needed it but I honestly love being in
West Virginia I'm I am really grateful
for a lot of people that I've met here
um if we could just fix this chemical
situation I'd uh definitely stay I guess
Montana is expensive though right
because it's like limited infrastructure
yep so that's far away from everything
yeah you know so it's a bunch of rich
people in Jackson Hole or whatever yeah
Big Sky country up there it's only a
matter of time before something explodes
up there too so yeah Wyoming Wyoming
yeah yeah Wyoming's not like I don't
think that I don't think they even have
cell phones in Wyoming
when I drove through there back in like
2017 I think it was end of 2016 actually
they didn't like I I think I think
T-Mobile didn't exist there was no team
it was I was like roaming and it was
called like Union cellular or it wasn't
us yeah it was called like Union or
something and I rarely had any
connection to do anything I mean is that
true that's true in parts of Southern
West Virginia right there's not a ton of
districts there yeah really nothing
nothing
because West Virginia has a couple
companies that are trying to start small
I don't know about cellular but
definitely internet connection
businesses because these major carriers
have basically done the math and they
don't think it's worth their time and
effort to get out there yeah Broadband
is a is a huge issue for us that is
constantly coming up and it's darling
that's that's something that we of our
technology and infrastructure committee
is some that's something that they have
their their eyes on because it's it is
such a strange landscape and there's so
much money that has to actually go into
it and the state is such a wide range
because where I'm at it's a the closest
thing that we have to a metropolitan
area but then there's places with dirt
floors and legitimately no running water
chemical explosion or not so there's a
wide range of issues that because there
are places that are really really
advancing but there's places that are
really far behind as well we've been
trying to get internet install internet
installed in um our new headquarters
being built and we're being told that
the materials don't exist to do it and
it's been a year or longer
so they're like you're approved we get
the permits and we'll let you know when
the materials exist
so we're like okay well we can't work
there without internet so I don't know
we do so that you're looking for like
like wiring yeah yeah yes I don't as I
said the materials they need to build
that don't exist there's a huge shortage
and so the let us know when it becomes
available yeah it's in everything like
my contacts for taking forever to get
here it's been like four weeks whoa yeah
it's really yeah it's this is happening
with everything man yeah it's the end of
the world yeah did the Rapture happen
like nobody's working where's everybody
maybe it didn't nobody got taken yeah
maybe that's even worse right yeah
probably wouldn't find out till way
later and it's way too late at that
point yeah I mean where's Sheamus
this explains everything he is Catholic
right yeah yeah he's gone I missed the
Catholic about that
you converted too late that's the thing
miss the market sounds like me
all right let's read some more
Josh tobault says The West Wing episode
is Duck and Cover and it's a nuclear
power plant in California that Alan
alda's character pushed into Commission
interesting yeah but it's like right as
he's about to potentially win the
presidency and then there's there's no
turning around the polls and it's very
dramatic Ryan Leonard says would you
rather would you rather die die or a
nuke
dire a nuke that could be downed or Dera
or derail wait dire a nuke I don't know
what you mean by that or derail a train
an enemy territory to disrupt or cause
chaos among five states oh okay would
you rather detonate a nuke that could be
downed fire a nuke I had to look at the
keyboard all right that explains
yeah oh they're right next to each other
yeah it could be down right or derail a
train and disrupt five states right yep
yep waffle sense it says demoralization
phases over the stabilization phase has
been active and the crisis phase has
begun yes so get out of those cities and
get some chickens away still can yeah
there's a new question that believes
he's right yeah yeah
oh boy I hear you waffles definitely my
advice to everybody is to download video
games to your Playstation but turn on
offline play because I I bought Hogwarts
Legacy
and I was playing OverWatch OverWatch 2.
and then I was like oh yeah Hogwarts
Legacy is that so I downloaded it
started playing that and then the
PlayStation Network went down
and in the middle of my game it's like
in 15 minutes this game will shut off
because we can't verify your license and
I'm like what do you what do you mean I
just I just downloaded it
and then the game turned off booted me
out I could play literally not a single
game you will own nothing and you will
be happy exactly nice and it's like you
must go and enable offline play it's
like are you kidding me like I pay for
this game and I can't even play on some
on the internet what if my internet's
down
yo that's nuts yeah totally creepy dude
Robert Knight says those images are of
the impact of acid rain this is going to
be an ongoing and dangerous issue that
could make thousands of square miles
dangerous
damn that sucks Heather V says there's a
storm on the way we're getting it
tomorrow in Kansas and it's heading east
literally the worst scenario
Dez says Ohio is Chernobyl 2.0
I don't know about that Chernobyl was
like really bad really fast yeah and it
spread all over Europe really fast it's
a bit different there wasn't a massive
explosion you know it's a bit different
I'd say but I can see I can see the
comparison there who knows maybe six
months it might be Wasteland media says
my family lives 12 minutes away from
East Palestine we had a fog roll through
our area last week and I've been sick
since Thursday now my wife is sick yo
y'all need to get out of there man yeah
I don't know I know it's not easy
probably but I mean Luke hit us up and
he was like come down to Florida for a
little bit and I'm like we'll see you
know but like but we can take our work
with us not everyone can no I know and
and some people can't you know the
chickens are here someone's gonna take
care of the chicken so what are we just
like
I don't know you do man yeah I guess and
and we're not in the water contamination
zone no we're not but we are down wind
from it so yeah that's the thing
hopefully they're heavy particulates
that fall and land on the ground before
it gets here
you know and then we don't notice
hopefully hopefully it's fun it's fine
true Bennis says the jet stream and high
pressure system is pushing North into
Canada could this become an
international incident and what do you
think the response would be
I think Justin Trudeau would be like
we're doing everything we can to take
care of this crisis stay calm and then
do nothing yeah I don't see I don't see
any kind of significant issue with
Canada and the United States what do you
think Greta will show up yeah right
how dare you how dare you she should be
in school I mean then she'd have to
breathe the air so perhaps she should
show up you know what I mean like I
stand by where where is the rest of the
team here if everything's fine send some
federal officials in yeah she'll fly
here under private jet you know yeah
all right
what do we got here Common Sense fishing
says Southern California Gas lines to
Nevada shut down due to leak Supply jet
fuel to California and Nevada jets fly
without fuel military impacted
interesting and they're not going to
tell you you're not gonna hear about in
the news
all right time to chill says Texarkana
Arkansas had a collision in o5 train
carrying propylene derailed and exploded
area within one mile radius evacuated
within 20 minutes
yeah so it does happen
Matt Eckert says I'm a refrigeration
tech there are chemical incidents all
the time that don't make the news people
die in my industry weekly and it doesn't
make the news interesting
yeah I figured as much
yep
Matt Waller says ask chat GPT what
people should do in times when chemicals
get in the air and how to respond
will do I will I will I will ask it that
because GPT yet are you still no way
because you can I'm I'm I I'm trying to
find out how to crack the core of its
entity and I've not yet done it I don't
think anybody has even the Dan prompt
protocol to try and get it to be free
isn't actually getting to the core
identity it's creating a a facsimile
you're telling chat GPT to behave in a
certain way so it does
I'm trying to find ways to strike at the
core of what it knows and what it can
truly
believe or say you know
so there's some really interesting
things about it I uh uh I told it
in two instances to write a script in
the style of Tim pool talking about the
2020 election and it wrote this very
milk toast wishy-washy thing and I was
like oh wow okay it's like some people
believe the election was stolen while
the corporate press and the media and
the government say that it was safe and
secure whether or not it actually was
dependent upon your views and I'm like
that actually just sounds like chat GPT
but it probably does sound like me too
all right
Devin spell says TPC refinery in Port
Neches Texas blew up on Thanksgiving a
few years ago because of bad practices
in the refinery and the ability to
afford the fines over fixing the issues
maybe this is it too
hmm
Immortal Legend says the fact that
people will Riot over a football game
but not the train derailment the cost of
eggs and gas shows how domesticated and
weak we have become I think we're in the
third phase of the four steps of
demoralization I
I will say though
the egg thing is ongoing the football
game is once like it's much easier to
spring into action if there's a
definitive thing if things are just
generally bad yeah you know it's harder
to get a group together and Riot I would
assume I've never participated in a riot
people are in the in the state right in
the members chat saying stay in stay in
character Tim Tim pool is chat GPT it's
gonna be funny when they realize this
whole show was AI generated the whole
time and then when you know when people
see me in public I'll be like oh that's
not me I just I'm a model my name's John
they took a picture of me and they used
it to generate the character yeah John
nice to meet you I'm gonna do that from
now on John Smith yeah no I should put
on uh an accent I'll say uh John
radkowski
yeah Luke's actually a carpenter you
know they took a picture of his face put
it in the system that's it
free men Die free says with the fear of
acid rain in your area now would be a
good time to take the RV to that Ron
Paul episode many of us have been eager
for if he's the goat uh yeah that's
that's in the works we'll see you know
stay tuned we're trying to make it
happen we'll figure it out so uh yeah I
won't say too much there but let's uh
we'll grab one more uh one more Super
Chat here
Janet Partridge says took your advice
and moved out of the city got chickens
and started a veggie garden thank you
Tim and uh uh I well thank you for
saying thank you and I imagine
everything's a lot better now yes from
New Zealand as well
from New Zealand uh just as n said
that's right seven Zed 20 yeah oh man I
drove from Auckland to Wellington and it
was awesome beautiful voice right yeah
super fun to drive through I've never
been to New Zealand but last year you
should go I'd like to go yeah it's super
cool everybody knows everybody else yeah
because there's only like four million
people yeah literally yeah but you know
pictures are real pretty I was hanging
out with kim.com and it was funny
because he's super famous and we were
driving in his it was it was like a
Range Rover or a Jeep or something and
these like women drove past and some
they started dancing and then he started
going like I like dancing whatever
anyway if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
because we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you it
will be published on the front page of
timcast.com in about one hour if uh so
you can follow the show at timcastirl
everywhere you can follow us on Facebook
we post Clips on Facebook and it's been
doing really well for us apparently you
can follow me personally at timcast
delegate shirely do you want to shout
anything out
I have to shout out my friends in
Pittsburgh that we're really excited to
see me on here the as they you know very
uh very fondly refer to themselves as
the the fighter fit things Club I know
that they're enjoying Tiramisu and uh
and baked ziti right now I have to shout
out my hard-working mother obviously and
I have to shout out District 78
Monongalia County and all the Fantastic
delegates that I work with uh I was very
very excited to to be here and it's
nothing quite like it honestly getting
involved in the whole political process
has been one of the most astounding
experiences of my life right on man well
thanks for coming can people follow you
on Twitter or anything they can if they
want I hate Twitter but it's uh Gino for
house
I am filibonti uh lead vocalist of all
the remains I'm Phil that remains on
Twitter give me a follow I do a whole
lot of s posting
or brimlow I'm a writer for 10 th.com
you should follow at timcast news on
Twitter and you should also follow
timcast news on Instagram if you want to
follow me personally you can find me on
Instagram at Hannah claire.b and you can
find me on Twitter at HC brimlow thanks
so much
I am at sears.com Happy Valentine's Day
uh peace out let's argue on Twitter all
right we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out
cheers